this show is brought to you by on it
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to save ten percent on all of their
amazing optimization products like alpha
brain new mood shroom tech immune and
shroom tech sport
kick that mu lee
wednesday october 12th
2016 you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here lisa here
my main man bruce buffer in the house
and it's the church
of what's happening now
little old-school janet jackson
when she was still rocking and rolling
oh [ __ ] kick it lee kick that mu lee
kick that [ __ ] muley i want to see
that board blow up in flames and [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] samsung phone blow that
thing up brother
oh [ __ ]
and you thought it was just another
wednesday night huh
[ __ ] here we go
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with thank you very much for clicking in
bruce buffy elisa what's the story lisa
yeah oh i'm doing good how you feeling
all right you have a good day today i
had a great day i went down to uh
beverly hills for a little bit did a
little work
and i went to the gym did you bump him
for the small 15 yeah are you still
[ __ ] around no i'm not i didn't ask
him for 15 grand yeah
[ __ ] guy i'm sorry i apologize what's
going on with you bruce buffett you're
back you're beautiful you got cancelled
so here we are this week you're relaxing
well got canceled man i'm glad i don't
have a tv show running right now you
would have scared the hell out of me
right there but you know what just got
back from manchester england uh crazy
crazy night of ufc action there i've
been traveling for them traveling for
other appearances and right now with the
show that was going to be in manila in
the philippines it got cancelled at the
last second on the ninth ninth hour and
you'll never hear me say this but uh i
mean
i i hate missing the ufc but i'm happy
that i got three weeks in town and gonna
relax and joy and and get back to uh
some other things i gotta do you know
you
a couple weeks ago i got put on the
opening weekend of the oddball tour
and it was just it came sudden it didn't
have a lot of advertising
the first week had a great lineup but it
just didn't fall the great way it should
have so they first canceled sunday and
saturday so all we had left was thursday
and friday how'd you feel about that you
like that i was pretty happy i was
moving that week
i didn't really want to [ __ ] come
back monday morning and have to get
right on the moving truck and pick up
and the baby and the wife
so i was pretty happy about that
and then there was rumors
that they were going to cancel thursday
and friday
and as soon as the rumor hit me monday
i i went and cut a chicken head like i
wanted to [ __ ] cancel and as much as
i did you know every once in a while you
need that's like when you're a kid
and they close school for two days oh i
love snow you catch a [ __ ] break
every once in a while you catch a little
break and it's when you need it in life
yeah but sometimes you don't catch that
break in your own direction you catch
that break because you're first into it
yeah
cause you're a pro and i consider myself
a pro
and
lee i'll tell you by the end of the show
okay thank you i appreciate it so nobody
i hope i impress
you're doing great by the end of the
show chris i gotta say i saw some moves
in the chair to janet jackson i was a
little impressed
i gotta be honest though i can only
dance when i'm sitting down i'm a big
guy i don't really have i have short
legs and i don't really move that well
but sitting down something about my i
have good hips
great have good hips just make sure you
got a chair that goes from side to side
i'm happy you're gonna have something
wait when isis captures you you'll need
those hips
god's sucker
what are you saying you know what it's
just that when something happens like
that okay
you'll work
every night of the week if you have to
you love what you do like i do i'm
passionate about what i do as far as
what i do in the octagon
and uh i don't ever want to miss a show
and every time it's a show it's my first
show and i you know i just had this
great passionate attitude that drives me
but i don't stop you know it's like when
i maybe should take a break i don't i'll
just keep working and i don't wear
myself out because you know no you take
care of yourself i take care of myself
you got to you guys just keep moving a
lot of people understand yeah this thing
called work that work ethic and work and
it's working smart
we don't have as much you said it's
smart working smart you and i don't have
a job
a job is nine to five monday through
friday you're home with a cat saturday
and sunday you go food shopping and
you're back at work monday nothing wrong
with that millions of people do that
lifestyle i love it i love the whole
diary there it's great yeah it's a
really it's it's a it it is what it
[ __ ] is yeah once you're in it you're
in it some of the people get
opportunities in life where they have a
job but not really
or they have a job and it's nights
and it's scattered maybe you work monday
tuesday and you have three days off and
you know everybody has a different
situation but then there's a thing
when you're in a certain position where
you're a one-man operation
and you're your own boss and when you
first get that
that
opportunity you run yourself ragged for
a few years because you you
overcompensate that's true but also too
joey
isn't a few years what's that your years
in show business easily total what 30 25
25
mine's almost 30 now
and uh with that being said
it's just that we love what we do like
you said i call it life by design
i don't take that away from anybody from
what they do in life because i've
certainly had plenty of nine to five
situations i've also owned companies
since i was 19 where it wasn't nine to
five it was nine to nine nine to nine
seven days a week you know what i'm
talking about so
we all have to pay our dues and i'll do
it and but even though they see you on a
show they see you in a movie they see me
in the octagon or another area of
entertainment where i work it's like oh
guy's got a so we i look oh he's got it
so easy so easy they don't take into
account that granted to put on that hour
of show for an artist or work uh by the
octagon for eight hours doing everything
from you know what you do in the octagon
to what you need to do out of the
octagon during that eight hours to make
the show flow and do your part of a huge
team you going to your one man show here
coming up this week
there's mental preparation there's
physical preparation there's so much
preparation that goes into a lot of
these things no matter how small the job
and just because it looks easy the trick
is you make it look easy and if you make
it look easy then all the professional
tactics you're putting into it are
working because you're not running
yourself into the ground and you keep
your performance for your people strong
you know
it seems like any whenever anyone says
something's easy they're never an expert
and if you're if you're if you're ever
in anything or
and even not even an expert just be
involved in anything
people always seem to say
they have respect for it people don't
really [ __ ] you don't ever include
travel time people understand that when
you live in california if you go get a
[ __ ] hot dog
it's a [ __ ] hour down the road you
know people that call you up and say hey
come on down to huntington beach
at three o'clock we're gonna have a
screening listen [ __ ] that means
i'll leave at 12. that's my whole
[ __ ] day doesn't mean just leave it
twelve means you're sitting in five
miles an hour traffic traffic so it's
amazing how when i've been i'm gonna be
here 20 years in january i have an
ethnic immigrant work ethic which means
i don't give a [ __ ] if there's an
envelope we're there
if i don't have to pass out and kill
myself or stab a [ __ ] we're
there you know i'm saying for the first
10 years i was here i got here in 97
and i didn't even know what you know
when i first met joe rogan for example
people go he's on news radio
i had no idea what news radio was
because that was such a comic i didn't
watch tv
i was so into it i didn't know what tv
was
i didn't know what tv was
until i got nypd blue and i finally
turned it on one night on a tuesday
night
and i watched it for like an hour that's
the first time in years
i had turned the 10 before that you know
i did time i'm snorting blow and eating
[ __ ] monkey and [ __ ] i'm not watching
tv
little [ __ ] days home in these days
you didn't have the remote control in
jail
i had a black and white tv in my room
but you know what i didn't even watch it
i had there was always something yeah
i'm just kidding there was always
something there's always something i i
don't understand it so last week uh
sadly you know
lee and i have this podcast
and basically we get together monday and
wednesdays and six out of 10 times i
leave on thursday mornings right and i
don't care if he lights himself on
[ __ ] five
for those thursday fridays saturday
i get back sunday i'm you know listen
man i'm a cuban [ __ ] jew
i don't know what the [ __ ] people are
talking about i cannot you know i get
the first flight out because there's no
terrorism at the airport sometimes we
fly together we fly together and that
flight is never [ __ ] delayed
so i get home my wife and baby i got a
three-year-old they're at church
i wait for them to come back i play with
the baby then when the baby goes down i
take a nap but when i get up and after
the hugs and the kisses and we eat the
family dinner my mind is already focused
on monday morning
i really don't give a [ __ ] about unless
omaha of omaha when was that show when
we were kids
yeah right well lawrence walk i really
don't give a [ __ ] about life i'm worried
about my monday you know
and it's funny that lee and i have had a
uh discussions i go lee on sunday nights
when i call you you know i'm asking you
questions i'm lying in the [ __ ] week
up well last weekend lee held on to his
girlfriend on sunday because it was
columbus day and i couldn't really talk
to him right and i had to say that only
like tuesday i'll leave from now on on
sundays i don't give a [ __ ] what
holidays we only work like three nights
here you gotta be attempted because i
can't really talk to him when somebody's
in the room it's [ __ ] rude you know
what i'm saying yeah he's got some
involvement with her and i gotta call
him up to ask him a question about the
computer or it's kind of weird the man's
got clash you realize well i could tell
when somebody's dead it doesn't take a
[ __ ] j it's like i don't pick up the
[ __ ] phone the daytona because you
got a three-year-old in front of me
right you ever call somebody who's got a
kid and they want to tell you a story
and they're talking to you and the kid
at the same time and you finally go
listen call me when the kid [ __ ]
leaves
because i can't so i don't pick up the
[ __ ] phone because i don't want to do
that to people right you always got to
plan ahead you know there's people you
go listen i gotta go you're talking hold
on let me take no there's nothing i'm
nothing we're from new york i gotta go
bam that's it the kid's [ __ ] outside
yelling you know
i'm the same way that's why i have that
problem because if the kid's around as
soon as the phone rings she wants to
have a conversation
they want all your attention
they want all your attention the same
thing when you're watching the tv with a
woman and some guy keeps calling you to
ask you a question they want all your
attention you're watching the movie
together this is my favorite movie this
is my favorite part this is what he
proposes i don't give a [ __ ] i'm trying
to make a living [ __ ] suck i'm trying to
bring an envelope home i don't give a
[ __ ] about your movie well if they you
know you get back to the 20
you get back to 24 7 aspects out when i
say it's not easy
we've we've worked very hard and
respectfully in what we do as everybody
does out there
there are moments when it's easy sure
because
you're catered to that i mean you're
entitled to that absolutely but it does
take an effort and like you said as soon
as you get home
and i do the same thing
i'm already plotting and planning and
everything i gotta do that week five
o'clock everybody go home everybody
takes a nap we hug once i get up and
then we dinner it's over i excuse myself
i might wait a little longer when my
wife plays the baby plays the computer
i'm right there and i'm on the computer
already setting up the week looking at
my schedule making calls who's on the
podcast who's not one of the sponsors
for the week who's this you got you know
this is you that's why i don't like
working sundays
people always say well you're a prima
donna you don't know i knew and i knew
when i was featuring i hated working
sundays i didn't see the point of doing
a show for 80 people who didn't want to
[ __ ] be there right you know sundays
is family day in the summer and the
winter is football i got to get up after
a football game i've been eating
pretzels and and [ __ ] lipton onion
dip all day i'm farting like a [ __ ]
you know i got gas masks coming out of
my ass am i in danger of this tonight i
mean what you guys have for dinner just
give me the warning now okay no no no no
no no
okay but uh no we're just saying that
it's it's who wants to do something on a
sunday when i could do
30 things in my house on a sunday night
oh i'm listening when you do comedy they
want you to work once you work sunday
night for 80 people
to have you there for one and then you
can't even catch the [ __ ] red eye
you're stuck there all day your family's
eating at home by themselves and you're
stuck there action is here monday
morning i want to be here monday morning
yeah you got to well you got to weigh
each offer that comes in i'm sure you
turned down a lot of offers but you know
you got to weigh in many ways a the
money
a is this my thing you know am i going
to feel good about this because i'm sure
like me you've done stuff that you
didn't really want to know no no no no
and then pick what's right for you and
you know just put it all together in the
best way this is about you it's like
your focus as you do so well as any
artist has to do when i say an artist
there's all different kinds of artists
you're an artist and what you do you're
an artist
and it's all about what sets and works
for you because like you said
walk into that octagon you know it's a
lonely sport in the world a one-man
fighter but i mean who's going to fill
in for you joey
you got to fill him for joey joey's sick
you got to fill him for joey you get
what i'm saying
oh last we got to go on stage with
[ __ ] vertigo
how the frick did you go on stage with
vertigo how do you do that there was a
thousand ten thousand people and i'm up
there the second night in irvine are you
are inclined to get vertigo what no why
did you get backache and i [ __ ]
started eating those leaves because okay
now the truth comes out no i you know i
had this back pain and i don't have time
to be [ __ ] sick i'm like i'm saying
i'm like you don't you look on the back
of the package it says you know
two treats acrophobia three treats
vertigo you know no no what i do is with
i leave advil i'm a whole pot smoker so
i have a problem with reefer i can't
smoke the same reefer do you know how
people buy a pound of weed and smoke it
for a year i can't do it i gotta change
in the same week two days
i do the same thing with
pain pills like not pain pills uh
pharmaceuticals but aleve tylenol
yeah none of that none of that rough
stuff no no no no no no no no no octan
stuff so something happened i started
eating those and i started
you know when you get to a certain age
you pee at night
so after a certain age you start look
after a certain time you're still just
looking are you saying anything i pee at
night all the time oh you do pee at
night all the time wait till you pee
every hour on the [ __ ] hour wait a
second do you ever get rid of that
moment when you wake up to pee and you
just don't want to get out of bed you're
telling yourself you can hold it you
know it'll be okay until the next four
hours goes off
and you pee yourself no no no no no no
no no no that like obvious that hasn't
happened joey i think he's got a
storyboard horrible that
you know so sometimes i don't drink
water at night well one of those nights
when i didn't drink water they [ __ ] up
my kidneys i went to acupuncture she
moved the energy and it became vertigo
so it would hit me like 10 minutes
before i got the [ __ ] irvine meadows
the one night the one night that hit me
on stage the one that hit me when i was
laying in bed beat that one
and then that monday it went away so i'm
cool with that how long's the last
10 seconds 15 seconds oh 15 seconds of
your [ __ ] life and you just walked
out on stage or in the middle of your
act i'm in the middle of my act when i
shifted awesome to the room just went
did you play with it when you came out
of it did you play with it with the
other eyes i just stood there like i was
the [ __ ] deer in headlights
and i kept doing my joke i kept
breathing out of my nose kept breathing
kept breathing i left my hand out like i
was surfing
to be cute but i wasn't being cute i was
balancing myself and uh
so that was the deal you know what the
audience they probably thought it was
all part of the thing they didn't even
know yeah you know i didn't fall over
and i didn't pull a beyonce or a madonna
and fall everywhere
have you ever had to cancel a show bruce
no
no i've had uh no i never have as a
matter of fact up until about three
years ago or maybe i know it could be
longer i can't get i'm really lousy with
time
it's just time flies by so fast it blows
me away so
answer your question no i've never
canceled i've been canceled on but i've
never canceled a show i've done a show
with
104 degree temperature so dehydrated by
the end of the show the paramedics
wanted to send me the hospital to you
know whatever but i look at the fighters
in case of those shows i look at the
fighters and i just like i don't care
what i have but you know my back's out i
blow the acl on my knee and i've got to
do three shows in a row the variance
starting the very next day you know with
one leg and it doesn't matter these guys
and girls ladies and men are fighting
they're fighting so i just think hey i
can get through this you can always get
through it what's that what's the old
added showy the show must go on yeah
nobody no needs to know how we feel
we're just there to do our jobs
my mom used to have this thing like
you couldn't in my house when i was
growing up when i got out of catholic
school my mom and i had a deal and her
deal was listen
if you're sick just do me a favor go to
school
if you puke at school i'll come get you
and take you for food and take you home
and take care of you but you just can't
lurk around here
and that always stayed with me like
people would just stay home you can't
stay home you gotta do something
i mean listen you can't go to an office
when you work in an office with the
[ __ ] flu or you're coughing you're
gonna get everybody [ __ ] sick you
know what i'm saying people don't think
about it they do it and that's what
people could see yeah that's why people
get sick throughout the office but
you know if you work outside or if you
work working a [ __ ] truck and you're
by yourself from that truck you know you
go to work until you can [ __ ] pass
i come from a different
whatever than most people like i didn't
have insurance so i moved to l.a
you were really [ __ ] years ago you
were 4
i used to take my own teeth out with
wrenches and [ __ ]
with jack daniels and the grandma blow
can we just talk about that for a second
joey you [ __ ] believe why the frig
would you do something like that what
was the reason for that [ __ ] dentists
i hated it were you higher than a kitty
or what no i just i i would i would be
you know i would be on the road doing
comedy i'd get a toothache and after a
week i couldn't take another one i go
[ __ ] it i'd go to kmart i'd buy a wrench
and a couple airplane bottles and i'd
get a [ __ ] half gram or some [ __ ] in
michigan
and i'd rub it on the gum and then they
get infected and i got it abscessed
oh you have no [ __ ] idea for years i
had no insurance
so just tell me one did you do this more
than once twice twice
ended it f up each time
uh years later one time it just broke
and the bone was still in there and it
just it was just an abscess so if people
came around me that i hate it i could
squirt it it would fill over here a
little size oh and i would go and it
would go and it would jump on people's
shirt and [ __ ] it was and if you smelled
it it smelled like [ __ ] katrina feet
or something
so wait you're saying you didn't go to
the hospital or the dentist after you
broke it off in your gum you know what
people say if you have an abscess you're
gonna die i walked around like for five
[ __ ] years well let's okay slow down
okay
to your audience which a lot of them i'm
sure have stolen off their minds right
now let's not preach the fact that the
abscess
you can walk around with it for five
years i don't think you want to give out
that kind of community
i had leakage out of my dick for like
eight or nine years i didn't give a [ __ ]
did these years ago i was younger what
do you think you got you got tw what are
your choices you got gun or rear you've
got erythritis which is a urinary
infection most men think they got the
clap when they get it because it's the
same thing but it's just a urinary
infection you probably had a constant
urinary infection who the [ __ ] knows it
didn't no i take that back you probably
had everything yeah
it didn't it didn't bother me at all
you know what once you drink that hudson
river water you're good for you're good
for life yeah you don't even have to
have sex after that you got it all it's
like one stop i tell people we were down
there one time me this kid mike asked
isn't this crazy kid johnny lopez
when i was a kid there was his family
the lopez let me tell you how crazy that
was the mother was dying of cancer
and she didn't want the pain pills
she gave them to the boys to sell
and what they basically were were like
[ __ ] tumults
that would kill a mule they were like
sp54s or something like we were doing
quaaludes that were
the 714 express
were these [ __ ] blue and white pills
that your world would end
it would just end like it was just a
complete like he would tell you don't
drink with this don't do nothing we were
kids he was selling for like 30 bucks a
piece
that long ago the mother was dying of
cancer she didn't give a [ __ ] if she
died she wanted blow so they sold the
pills for coke no no tremendous
we got to do a story on this family
they're like buying up
did they what is that like buying up
yeah can you get some pills get your
blow still all bought up they're still
alive
but she used to sell [ __ ] her tumals
and those things would [ __ ] kill you
i would eat like a half
and i'd be on fire
you go to bed wake up you're still
[ __ ] rocked when you wake up that's
craziness i get to say i pain pills
i refuse them there's one big reason
they stop you up like like mount olympus
but aside from that
like when i had my as an exam when i had
my first acl when i had that operation
welcome to the next morning it's like
they're giving me all these pills and
actually what the the pain was not that
bad
so i i stopped the
oxy or whatever they gave me the time i
just threw it away i said i hate this
sometimes i've seen too many people get
hurt on that stuff sometimes i gotta be
honest with you sometimes
when you have surgery
as a human being you don't know what to
really expect no you don't so the first
couple days you just feel something and
you take the pain pill the amount they
tell you
and then like let's say you forget one
time not that bad and it's not that bad
and you're like why am i taking this now
if like this last surgery i had i always
prepare for a surgery
once you have
surgery just tell me how you okay once
you have once you have a surgery
you understand the preparation you hear
people tell you you're like [ __ ] this
guy i'm not gonna listen to him he don't
know what he's talking about but then
when you're in a toilet and you're 10
days in without taking a [ __ ]
and you're sitting there and you wish
your [ __ ] would just rip open and
you're crying and you're thinking you
have to go to the hospital ten days you
gotta stick a finger up your [ __ ] and
pour you like a rock and start eating
yeah because it's now you learn so
that's where the preparation goes in so
they come to you lisa not just
preparation h the preparation no no
that's what preparation once that
happens to you and you finish that pain
medication and you don't [ __ ] take
care of yourself after that [ __ ]
prescription wears off first off if you
take that full medication or whatever
they give you i'm going to tell you
something as a friend and you know i'm
not lying i know i don't it's
psychological abuse for four days once
you get off that there's withdrawal
factor
excuse me there's a withdrawal factor
and you start being
i'm not going to say you get suicidal i
don't want people to say i said i got
suicidal i'm just telling you i didn't
feel how i usually felt and were you
taking them all day like no i was taking
them not knowingly it's until you don't
take him and you go hey oh i didn't take
this for six hours i feel good so we're
also geared and stimulated also you're
geared for pain the doctor you know the
doctors do their job they gear us we
think it you know you think oh i got to
take the pain pills then all of a sudden
when it's just a graduating return you
take the pain pills when maybe you do
have the pain but it's not the same
a couple days later you're taking the
same dosage for like five well wait a
second this is what i understand listen
mr uh
buffer
uh from having conversations with other
patients the pain's not gonna be that
bad tylenol pm or tylenol extra strength
to do
but in case i gave you a prescription
you know what
why are you doing that
i never understood that why don't you
tell me that
there'll be a prescription available to
you for 72 hours only at cvs if you need
it after the surgery
i like that they give you the pill
before it so you have it when you get
home so you have to leave the [ __ ]
house when you're well
there's another way to do it give them a
prescription
for if they need it
and give them a two-day dose just to
take home in case they really do need it
and that gives them the time to call in
the prescription there you go instead of
i had a situation where i came home when
they pulled uh one of the rear teeth
right
the painkiller had not gotten to my
house yet
and i was a kid i'll never forget this
and this and i literally was grabbing
the side of my bed you know the pain was
so crazy you know what i was going
through and i had to wait that that
two-hour period until finally they
called in the prescription to get it it
just didn't work but it had been sent
home with one or two
and waited and then had the prescription
in my hand to buy more because when
those two are gone they're gone they're
gone you know and then you're either
that guy or girl that's going to go hmm
well i'll be cool to have him around
maybe i'll sell him my friends or you
know that guy or the girl is going to
like hey i don't need this scrap you
know but i got it if i need it i got it
you know it's all about the individual
i i keep it like i had a and not about
the it started no problem not the
individual it just that would be more
interesting but getting back to my point
is
pharmaceutical companies help pretty
much help when i say help i don't know
if it's helped but run this country you
know money those doctors are geared to
prescribe drugs
what's the difference between a
psychologist and a psychiatrist
a psychiatrist can prescribe drugs
you can still go talk to somebody sit on
the couch and
pay them 350 an hour to listen which is
what they do and you're working out your
own problems hopefully but one guy can
give you the scripts
that's something that's but it comes
down to financial too at the same time
they're geared for it never change this
hurts their mo
i've never understood
uh though the pain pills because i've
i've never done them
but i had some friends who did
and the way they described it it just
said they made them feel itchy
and anxious and that just didn't yeah
that depends on the individual and that
depends on what they're taking that's
not gonna be the same for everybody
maybe the same for them right that's
true the pain pills don't you know
another misnomer too some people think
is that they got a gashing when it's
hurting it's like that pain pill sending
all the signals right here
so that you know you don't hurt here no
it's it's
it's in here it's affecting the portion
of your brain that registers pain i
can't talk about it like i'm
knowledgeable at it because i'm not i
just know in theory what they do and
then they're one of the hardest and not
the hardest things to get off if you
become addicted
chevy chase he was addicted to pain
pills for his back all those pratfalls
he took on saturday night live he's got
issues right now and they're weighing it
back to all that
so no it's i listen let me say let me
tell you about my first surgery knock on
wood
i never cop to no surgery until i'm
about
maybe 10 years ago 12 years maybe 10 12
years that's a lot that's when you last
said so 40. the first time i ever have
surgery okay i got this [ __ ] lump
coming out of my neck
hunchback style yeah like out of this
muscle right here and i'm not saying
nothing you know me i'm a die-hard i'm
scared of needles
if i'm gonna die [ __ ] it i'll die like a
soldier and [ __ ] and every time i get
excited
this lump would come out
tremendous i'd be on stage yelling you
[ __ ] sucka chino xl [ __ ] you and when i
get off the lump would be elevated my
neck would be red okay
i finally showed my wife she gets pissed
off she goes you gotta go to the [ __ ]
doctor
i go to the doctor
uh like what was it going on for maybe
four months to go to the doctor i think
it just get bigger and bigger yeah it
was getting bigger and bigger it's
amazing she hasn't killed you by now so
now i go to the doctor they tested it's
not cancer but they got to get it out
yeah so the guy talks to me so you know
me i'm honest juggle listen doc
i like to smoke pot i like to snort blow
you know what do you know and he goes
listen
smoke pot for like two weeks out but the
coke give it a break right now like 60
days out i i'd rather you not do it you
know i'm like okay
i say [ __ ] i'm like an 8 ball and do
a going away party for coke you know
what i'm saying right you know how you
do it you always got to have one last
bomb boy go out
bang it yeah so
i [ __ ] get the eight ball or whatever
i got i don't know i'm like i may be
exaggerating and i have my last cocaine
run and i smoked eight packs of
cigarettes and oh yeah i jerk off 80
times the whole [ __ ] thing
and
three days later you know i would always
go three days
three days is the most i could stay
clean
and i got a week out of the [ __ ]
surgery bruce buffer wait then i'm still
snorting up a stone
a week out of the surgery and he wanted
60 days he wanted 60 days he wanted 60
days before he went in the hospital no
yeah so he's like
you know he don't know nothing i'm three
days out of your [ __ ] i'll quit three
days before the surgery here i am two
days before the surgery
snowing up a storm
so finally i stay off it the one night
and i stay off it the night before the
surgery
now the night you know i'm a [ __ ]
old-school junkie at this time the night
before the surgery i got everything
prepared i swing over i give the coke
dealer 100 bucks
i tell the weed guy to have everything
ready for me at the weed store i'm
having surgery at six in the morning
i'll never forget this bruce buff i
[ __ ] go home
go to sleep wake up go take the fat ball
out of my neck i wake up in recovery i
see all these filipinos everywhere
i haven't snored it in three [ __ ]
days you know what i was going through
at this point i can imagine all i was
holding out for was this [ __ ] fat
ball on my neck that's all yeah i asked
my wife what's going on she's like they
want you to rest here for like four or
five hours i'm like four or five hours
[ __ ] you i listen to me i got 350s
strategic
street
four or five fifties will buy you out of
any hospital in america right yeah four
fifties fifty dollar bills not twenties
they don't work
100 works anyway 100 works on the blind
man but a 50 is good enough
i got 350 dollar bills i knew that would
get me to the door you know what i'm
saying that would get me to the door
i wake up
i'm naked i got the [ __ ] robe with my
ass out my wife's looking at me and my
wife and my wife pulled my wife you know
she don't get high
but she knows what i'm going through at
this time she knows everything about you
and she's not married to me at the time
but we've been together for [ __ ] uh
five six years she knows everything
about you so the next thing you know i
[ __ ] pull the intravenous out of my
arm you know me dog
but i see a little black dude with a
wheelchair come here
i go
i got my clothes next to me
i pull a 50 i put it in his hand the dog
get me out of his dog let's do it
this [ __ ] sits me down i got the
intravenous but i still got another tube
in me for some reason right we're
ripping out the nurse stop it stop it
the thing's going off
the doctor's cycle i mean i got myself
out of there
it was it was one of the most
embarrassing things i ever did i gave
the guy a hundred bucks
my my poor wife was pale like she knew
something was uh we get in the car i
tell her you got to stop at the wheat
store she's like why why do you need
marijuana i go for my [ __ ] pain they
already had a bag waiting for me
and then i made a stop at a friend's
house to get a book he bought from me
but she didn't know it was the coke
dealer but so i go hold on here i am
with the robe
the thing around my arms oh you're
walking in like that into the coke
dealer's house with the [ __ ] bracelet
on i'm an animal
with a thing on my arm i look at the guy
that robert de niro shot and taxi in the
neck yeah this is him when he got out of
the hospital i got a bandage on my neck
this is an embarrassing story barbara
i walk in the coke dealer's house i get
whatever half eight ball i go home
it's the surgery was at six in the
morning it's eleven o'clock
it's eleven in the morning i'm still
under the anesthesia i'm still hearing
people yelling and getting stabbed and
screaming
i go back to the apartment i'm sitting
there maybe an hour
and i said [ __ ] this i gotta do a blast
i did a [ __ ] blast of coke and i
popped the stitch
i could feel the blood going i was
actually gonna ask you that
of course you did that's how disgusting
i was do you understand me like when i
think of those black people say to you
how do you feel let me tell you how bad
i feel let me tell you a story that's
going to make you feel really [ __ ]
bad about me and i'll never forget that
my wife comes in the kit you know the
living room she said are you bleeding i
go no
i just poked myself with them my wife
was gonna [ __ ] kill me
you know she couldn't tell i was coked
up because i only did two bumps and by
that time it was i was like 20 minutes
in you sure she couldn't tell you no no
no no because i didn't do it in front of
my wife right okay i never did it in the
daytime
and i only did it when she was in bed
see it's amazing how you do something
that is done with a lot with little or
no discipline but you're so disciplined
about how you do it oh my god i didn't
want them that makes sense
very seldom would you see me at the
comedy store with a blast because i
wouldn't do it until i got off stage it
doesn't i would think that i would think
to i know a lot you know a lot of comics
and a lot of people in show business
whatever you know
blow themselves up before going on stage
but make you perform better or make it
perform worse for me
when i first got into colony in 1991
saint patty's day 1992
i was working with a comic named troy
baxley
and i know troy was a little crazy
i forget who the feature actor was i was
the mc and i bought like a half a gram
of coke a grandma coke
and thank god i did like two lines and i
went up on stage and i died
and i never did it again but ah there
you go it got to the point where if you
did it the night before
you're following me yeah and went on
stage it's like if you had a big show
on a saturday but you went on friday and
got blasted till about three
ate some [ __ ] did like an eight ball
when you got up monday when you're
announcing the names
no no you're not really connected well
because if i didn't get up to monday and
i started announcing the names i
wouldn't be connected i would have been
fired saturday from mississippi
i'm like a nun the night before a fight
no no
a lot of people don't understand that a
lot of people understand that everybody
remembers guns and roses in the
beginning when they were doing the
american
awards nodding and everybody was on
heroin yeah everybody thought that was
cool they don't know that after one year
they look at that [ __ ] and they go i'm
not doing that no more and they become
musicians you know they evolve you know
with comedy was the same thing towards
the end of my i would get [ __ ] drunk
on stage knowing i had a package waiting
for me somewhere right because i would
never drink unless i knew for a fact the
package was waiting somewhere right i
didn't like alcohol i don't like alcohol
again discipline you have that great
discipline when you play with no it's
like lee calls me calculated i did
cocaine calculated
when i went on the road with rogan rogan
hates drugs so much
especially cocaine
that i hate cocaine that i would be so
cool even if i had it in my pocket i'd
play with joe
until the end of the show and also i'd
disappear
and joe knew he wouldn't ask the next
day
he would be disappointed but it was what
i would do
i would disappear i wouldn't make it
embarrassing i wouldn't go to the bar
and talk to people with my jaw going
no
i think in the 20 years i know jojo saw
me one time coked up because he told me
he wasn't going out so i got all blasted
at the store and there he was he showed
up because now i changed my mind i'm
like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and he's like get in the car with me
went to do comedy somewhere and in the
car i was out of my [ __ ] mind i
couldn't even look at him
i couldn't could he tell right away he
knew he's not stupid he grew up in a
[ __ ] pool yeah
you know so
that's that's that's [ __ ] up that's uh
that's the surgery story there you go
yeah that's the life like it's one of
those one things you just didn't want to
happen
no way no i thought when i went to that
doctor and he goes yeah don't get high
for 60 days i'm like you know what
i could do that with my eyes closed [ __ ]
i was so buried at that time and i did
not know i had no knowledge once you
realize when you realize that
there was a problem you had to deal with
i mean when did you finally realize that
i had realized that this is 2006.
and what was your this is january of
2006. let me tell you what really
happened let me tell you a real yeah
that moment when you knew let me tell
you what it was like
you know all right i got locked up
okay okay so i started in 79
i quit when i got locked up no i quit in
85.
i quit for a year and a half
and then i did it again
and i got locked up and
an hour after i got locked up i snorted
coke
straight
like i came to a conclusion that you
know what
i'm gonna do this two three nights a
week this is just who i am i'm not gonna
fight it i'm not gonna feel guilty no
more i'm not gonna kick my i'm not gonna
do it eight nights a week i'm gonna
become a comedian
but my thing will be instead of going uh
shooting pool instead of going to play
poker instead of having underwear i
stopped buying underwear instead of uh
you know you just sacrifice certain
things
this is what i'll do i'll do cocaine and
i'll smoke marijuana when you were i
don't want to date nobody i'm not going
to buy nobody dinner for those broads
i'm not buying you dinner we're gonna
meet doing blow
we're gonna do a grandma blowing eat
your [ __ ] you're gonna lick my nut sack
well on one aspect of all the time you
saved what's that think of all the time
yeah yeah yeah no no no no my
relationships went from five hours down
to a 20 minute period 90 minute period
at night we woke up i'll call you next
monday there was no monday you know what
i'm saying i was already on a greyhound
bus going to the next city what were you
saying lee i'm sorry
during those 60 days like when you were
supposed to be not doing coke would you
each night would you for like each day
would you pretend you weren't gonna do
it not pretend but think you weren't
gonna do it and then at night you'd
falter there were some days that i
didn't i didn't even think about it
until eight o'clock
eight o'clock at night i get this
anxiety and this pain in my bones well
that was the time you started anyway
right
that's the time
that my mind would start playing tricks
with me to go get it and then once i get
it i'd hold on to it so i did comedy
and once i got off stage i was showing
leader route last night
because in those days my route was easy
i i
nine out of ten of my shows were at the
comedy store
so i wouldn't pick up cocaine though i
was done at the commies though
now i lived in schrader
let me see i lived on 1440 north
schrader
that's by hollywood and vine
okay
the comedy store is two blocks
west of fairfax or three or four blocks
west that really doesn't [ __ ] matter
right okay so i had two spots in those
days i had a mexican restaurant across
from the guitar center
i've eaten there right and then i had an
isolated guy over by rouse behind there
so it was all on the way home i even
bought coke calculated i even bought
coke
economically you know what i'm saying i
knew these guys in silver lake
that had coke right from the [ __ ]
colombians off the chip yeah nobody
spoke english the whole thing but that
meant i had to go all the way to silver
lake and back from silver lake with
cocaine in your car i had another dealer
that i went to only after two he was
homeless tremendous
a dealer who's homeless tremendous
western
and sunset sure it was good [ __ ] oh my
[ __ ] god
and this is how crafty this [ __ ]
was he lived behind the burger king
there on western right now they changed
into something this is 15 years ago all
you had to do was drive on sunset
make the right of the left and then
drive back down
and make that right and also you hear
like somebody chasing a car and it'd be
him
it was hysterical it's funny he chased
the car
he'd pull up to the car okay he had it
awake i get it and before you said
anything
he would have a coke rock and he put it
in your nose to make sure you weren't a
cop
isn't that well let's say you're a cop
and he sticks it in your nose isn't that
assault who the [ __ ] knows he's homeless
already he would put a coke rock in your
nose to make sure you were in the car
then he'd take your order you gave him
the cash he gave you a coke rock no
envelope no bindle no nothing just put
it in your hand you put it in the center
compartment and drove back off on sunset
like nothing happened you didn't pay for
the first coke rock up the nose right
there that was the three that was yeah
that was the taste okay
you know you bring back uh something i
remember it's kind of like six degrees
of separation i don't have a cocaine
story for you but i got a story comedy
story story for you in malibu where i
grew up i moved there when i was 15 from
philadelphia right
so when i had
probably i was like 21
and i'd already started my first company
and i was living in malibu and and
during the rains after the fires when
there's a big fire it loosens the soil
the roots have to grow and the soil
doesn't stay strong so when the rains
came the mudslides hit and then the hill
came down and you couldn't get in or out
of malibu on the coast highway so ice
lived my dad
had a business contact that was the head
of the hide house at the time next to
the comedy store they used to call it
the riot house because that's where yeah
yeah
that's that's what we started zapping
the tvs out the windows all those
stories were all that place
and um i lived there for a month
and this was back i'm talking like 1982
right 81
and when i'd see all the comics i used
to see back there because i would go
almost every friggin night i loved
getting back from work unless i was
chilling i used to go to the westwood
comedy store and watch david letterman
host every night during the week and i
that was my friday date night but here
to go there and uh god i can't begin to
tell you the comics i saw was amazing
and it was great just to go from my
place to the comedy store see a great
two-hour session
go out somewhere and laugh and i still
say when you go out on a date with a
girl take her to dinner or whatever
guys one of the greatest things you can
do with a girl because girls just love
to laugh that's when guys have game or
they don't girls love to laugh right
comedy store comedy shop and you're this
really good one it's a great date it's a
great great can you imagine like if you
instead of going to a bar like cheers
you just went to the comedy store right
now and you were a cool guy yeah and you
became friends with the comics that's
what i did with them
i couldn't say that but that's what i
did you bring a [ __ ] date
and you start talking to like crystal
you're like you know for a little while
chris is nice to you because we're
cordial to you we'll talk to you for
10-15 minutes i mean i'll talk to you
you're very nice and not [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll talk you know who you you
know we know who the [ __ ] you're talking
to so uh it's really cool
it's really really cool i know it would
impress the shot of me if i was a female
or a woman it's also the closing ratio
it gives you yeah i would be really
impressed if i was a girl and you took
me there and you say hello and [ __ ] nice
dinner she's laughed all night and then
you know i'm telling you you're going to
go home with that i've seen some really
interesting people
hanging out at the comedy store like my
first it's a great is it still as much
fun to hang out now as it was 10 12
years ago
is there a difference do you notice the
difference the way comics come and go i
see the young guys that are there that's
what i'm talking having a great time i'm
a [ __ ] relic and a dinosaur
oh you know that they all look up to you
welcome back joey come on they're like
this is when i'm there
i feel like uh i'm really [ __ ] old
listen when i was 25 and i went to a
club i already felt old and i felt it
i felt it like i don't belong [ __ ]
here
you know so when i go to the comedy
store now it's not like i drink it's not
like i do blow i get there early i talk
to the bartender i talk to the
waitresses lee's back there with
[ __ ] another comedian with [ __ ]
then we go to the parking lot we
[ __ ] then we go home
yeah you know that's it i mean if
but when i was there my first five or
six years jesus christ
it was home it was home
and as [ __ ] up as it was
it was what's uh uh was missy short mr
short missy yeah she was very good she
did you get along with her did you meet
her how does she treat her comics i hear
she was really good to him well listen
man she
she liked the people she didn't like
people was like anything else it's a
tough girl and just the rumors that you
hear at one point it went to a head and
there were people who weren't happy with
it but it was a [ __ ] comedy story was
the home of richard bryan was the home
of [ __ ] dice clay with the homeless
sam kennison let me tell you something i
saw andrew dice clay when he first came
out here to la and he wasn't the
androidized clay we know and as big as
he got
and it was only a short time later that
i'm standing standing in the forum
right in la
sold out right looking there and sitting
in my seat afterwards and just looking
out sold out andrew dice clay remember
he used to fill like a 10 12 000 seat
arena it was crazy you know and i love
his little i love how he's traveling
around now he's got he's he's on the
road all the time i see the tv show
uh the tv show got picked up did they
get picked up got picked up for another
second season i'm really happy for him
the man can act listen out of all those
[ __ ] comics that got picked last year
nobody's show got picked up i read for
five comedy pilots
and andrew dice clay's got picked up
really that's it good for him yeah i'm
really happy for good for him
you said it earlier look it's hard
getting jobs hard the business is the
business is so hard it is if you're not
tough you shouldn't be even thinking
about this business especially your
business i don't think about the acting
side
at all anymore i know there's a job on
the horizon somewhere because you're
here you're going to get a call
you'll always get a
but as far as booking one i went in for
a role
two weeks ago that the [ __ ]
wrote for me
and i couldn't [ __ ] like him not
really but when as i was reading and i'm
like this is me
this is me for me like i know her the
lady who cast it she put me in four
other pilots
she wouldn't call me in if there wasn't
something there there's something about
casting directors when i've gone you
know for
the ones that i've gone for and stuff
and you walk out and you think
you think you did a great job especially
it's like a commercial for an announcer
like
you know like somebody just an announcer
whatever you walk in you walk out hey
that's like piece of cake to the back
man you never know what they're looking
for
i think they're
they're extremely unique in what they do
think about sitting there seeing
hundreds a day well this is the problem
that people think it's not what they do
it's that she's the voice piece right
for the four people that are sitting
behind so
let's say
we both go in for the part of gino
in the new [ __ ] sinatra movie right
he's still kicking her okay
i'm kidding i mean the one i'm made
about sinatra yeah they're always making
a movie about something they're trying
to make godly out of [ __ ] uh what's
his name now that's never going to go
because they can't get who got the part
to play uh
travolta
this is five years now they're trying to
get financing
they forgot that nobody even knows who
john gotti isn't not anymore anymore
millennials as they call them
millennials so there's a part of the
role for gina the guy is from brooklyn
okay
you're from brooklyn okay i'm from
[ __ ] jersey and you could hear it
down from jersey you know what man we
both go in there we both do a good job
and then they start looking at weird
stuff
what are the movies did you do
you know what relationship you have with
the other four [ __ ] people you know
i mean there's so many variables when
you get a film there's so many [ __ ]
variables
if if this guy gets the role then we'll
give it to the bruce oh yeah if this guy
doesn't get the role then it would look
good with bruce i mean there's so many
[ __ ] variables
but she's the mouthpiece her job is to
deliver
who did well in the room which is three
or four people
and their job is to figure out
who to [ __ ] hire
that's what it is it's east meets west
so
i never take it personally with a cast
in the right no you can't never since
day one i went through levels like
everybody else the first [ __ ]
15 auditions you go to you go through
craziness to see if you get them or not
then you learn then the next 15
you learn how to be cool
and you
you you have it together like you don't
show people you you're upset that you
didn't got something but then the next
like i'm to the point now when i walk
out of the room it's over
yeah it's over the buffer calls me and
goes hey joey what's up i just walked
out of fox i went in for a pilot that's
exciting
you know it's it's my dad always said
win like you used to it lose like it
doesn't bother you you got to walk in
there and you got if you can't handle
rejection in this business come on
forget about it okay rejection is such a
key factor but
uh you just got to keep punching man
well
okay
i gotta talk to you because i know and
learning how to get better your
auditions i know it's i know it's
burning a hole in your pocket what's
gonna talk
uh
the other day i'm watching this uh
it's a day it's saturday
so friday night
on
friday night i get back to my hotel room
at [ __ ]
and i know i don't want to talk about
this [ __ ] but just because my uncle
[ __ ] bruce wanted to talk about it
we'll talk about it for a few minutes
because it entangles something another
word that you said
what was the word called that you said
something about
doing it again tomorrow losing with
grace
winning like you're used to it and
losing like it doesn't bother you
win like you're used to it lose like it
doesn't bother you
you know and i know people don't want to
hear what i'm about to tell you but i'm
telling you from a different perspective
i don't know what's going on i have
felony so i can't vote so it don't
matter to me i grew up in north hudson
new jersey where every man either leaves
in a wheelbarrow or in a [ __ ] felony
it doesn't really [ __ ] matter so
politics don't affect me because i know
i still got to get up in the morning and
show somebody a gun and just to get mine
so it doesn't
for some people it's conversation it's
an identity in this country to be able
to go to starbucks and to be
knowledgeable to [ __ ] uh politics and
people look at you weird i don't pay
attention to it so friday and i get home
and he's talking about grabbing people's
[ __ ]
now saturday morning i wake up i go eat
breakfast i call lee i turn the tv on
and what's on the [ __ ] tv this is how
crazy the media is
what do you think is on the [ __ ] tv i
have no idea what killed the usfl
and i clicked the [ __ ] button i swear
to my mother's grave and it couldn't be
written better so every channel's god i
hate trump now oh and i put on [ __ ]
the espn 30 for 30
and there's the first line out of the
guy's mouth it's like trump's ego ruined
the usf and like they went from 30
people talking about trump now for an
hour i turned it off i had to leave i
went and smoked a joint but i thought
about something
i remember i remember being with ari at
a usa at a ufc event
and seeing herschel walker
walking in
all right
here he goes that's hershel walker
i go ari watch what happens when he sees
me and then churchill walker looked
around he went oh [ __ ] he gave me a hug
and i go harry goes how do you know him
i go i know him from his usfl days
from 1985 at the sheridan
when linhurst they used to have a happy
hour and all the brothers would go to
the
[ __ ]
and all the [ __ ] and [ __ ]
this is when everybody found out oj was
[ __ ] a white [ __ ]
it's all right the [ __ ] white [ __ ] you
know so my friend her house burnt down
and the insurance company put it at that
hotel so she used to call me no you
gotta get over here you have no idea
who's downstairs the giants the knicks
lawrence taylor it was a [ __ ] party
but the usfl right and i remember trump
and the whole [ __ ] deal but it's so
weird how even the media
spun it with who owns espn disney
and disney's against trump
obviously yeah most likely obviously but
listen that's not what i got out of it
you want me to say what i got out of it
that this motherfucker's been swinging
since 1985. trump yeah oh yeah he's been
playing deep he's been swinging i mean
you know so people say well he lost with
the casino he's a failure for this
here's a guy that never stopped trying
you know i don't listen we're not going
to get into it but i'm just saying
wouldn't i get started let me say
something but it's uh
it's so weird how he
was always swinging for the fences he's
if he didn't work at football [ __ ] he
bought a horse when that didn't work
[ __ ] it
and well that but at the other side
for years i was swinging at fences too
but it was other people that were paying
for my mistakes
well that's you know that's like being
in business we call it an opm or other
people's money they want to pay for your
mistakes that's what i was doing a few
years ago
just know that's and and actually i'll
be the first one like when i
in all the business i've been involved
in and everything else there's a saying
by a guy i think jay paul getty said
this i'd rather have one percent of 100
people's efforts than 100 of my own
i'll make more money i'll cover more
territory that's the whole point of
building a business so
people get caught up about their you can
see it on shark tank all the time about
percentages of companies it doesn't
matter how much percentage you have in
your life it's a matter of what you do
with the percentage that you have you
know you're either a doer you're not
and 98 of the people walking are all
everybody dreams everybody dreams about
everything we all do i'm a big dreamer
myself i know i'm sure you are so
especially given the night so as far as
that's concerned
two percent of the people put it to work
there's out of the 100 people out there
that want to be a com i can do
everything that made it live within
about 200 miles where you grew up
right you're the two percent or you made
it out you made it happen so it's a
matter just if everybody was a two
percenter
then the world will be kind of screwed
up because you ever hear those phrase
same phrases of pyramid you know that
this is a pyramid appearance scheme it's
a pyramid everything in life is a
pyramid whether you're a parent building
a family whether you're president
running the states or either president
of your company or in your case whether
you're the one man army that you are you
know and everybody underneath you is as
important as the guy on top you know all
those people shipping boxes and those
companies on the bottom
ladies and guys you know taking the
phones and everything they're just as
important as that top because without
them everything crumbles
so you've got to have that 98 whether
you're part of the 2 or the 98 it fits
it's just the way life is you know some
people call it top one i call it top two
for me the
the thing
about this election is like
i'm i come from a very liberal place
where it's
everyone's democratic i'm almost that
democrat
trump the thing about trump is if he
just hadn't said
some of that crazy stuff about mexicans
and just if he had just come out and
acted like a little bit normal i mean no
you're asking yourself you went on the
landslide yeah but not we'll see the
thing is no i disagree because the
reason he
comes out and talks like that is the
reason he is where he is that he can
come out and talk like that if he stops
being donald trump then that's not who
he wouldn't work it's a reverse it won't
work he his ego would never allow him to
do that
you know he's a fireball you know and
and yeah we saw this stuff last week i
mean
listen locker room talk is locker room
talk and then there's certain extremes
whatever and i don't condone you know i
love women don't get me wrong and i but
you know me joey do i ever talk
disrespectful about anybody and i know
how to talk funny right so there's a way
you talk and there's way not what we
said was wrong and if you can say well
that was 11 years ago like i think billy
bush the guy i was talking to said that
was like 10 11 years ago i become more
mature give me a break you're 28 year
old man now you're 38 year old man you
tell me that
that at 28 you didn't have enough you
know savvy in the business you're in so
now he's suffering this suspended him i
don't even know that i'll bring him back
because they're gonna have to send a
message in that case with what happened
but
trump is uh he's he's a powerful man and
as business-wise you mentioned that
uh that there's trump university you
know that came up and there's been like
3 500 lawsuits filed against it
the trump casinos they closed their
doors this week
they're done it's over it's totally
closed real estate has done quite well
in but all i know is one of over trump
don't want to vote for trump one vote
for hillary don't vote for hillary if
trump gets in office i'll tell you one
thing
that within
16 months
i'll give it two years give me some give
me a little leeway here there's going to
be a gold name of trump somewhere put on
the white house and i think we need to
like draw it and square it up and bet
five dollars in each square to see where
it's going to wind up because it's going
to wind up if he's president
i don't know that's going to be the best
thing that happens
so let me ask you something it's a scary
election joey it's very very scary you
were talking about the 2-1-1 like
for me it's like
i write the jokes i perform
i do a podcast
i prepare the podcast
lee puts him up he does all the
technical side my wife sends you
packages
you know my my agent books the [ __ ]
gigs
my theatrical world is done with you
know what i'm saying like i don't even
worry about that [ __ ] because when it
comes it'll come yeah when it comes to
that it comes right now i'm worried
about this so
i don't i still don't get your theory am
i on top am i in the middle absolutely
you're on top i was i was saying that
see we're all i believe that we're all
born
and created equal burning the ability of
course you know race is an issue in
cases but i'm talking about we're all
born and created equal and respect the
fact less we can throw higher
jump higher punch harder in sports i
mean what really separates we got lung
we got brain we got to put it to work
out of all the people in a group of 100
people within a 50 mile radius let's
call it a 500 mile radius 5 000 mile
race of people that wanted to become
what you wanted to become which was a
stand-up comic to do what it takes to
get there a lot of people dream of
thinking they try but you know it just
takes so much more you made it to the
two percent
you know you just kept punching and
punching and punching and you know how
you know how to do every aspect of your
business from what you're telling me
so you can't train anybody else do it
unless you know how to do it yourself
and and this kind of business including
mine managing my brother's you know
career and everything else i don't want
a big office i had offices that had
you know 150 employees 40 000 square
feet the bottom line is you can get it
all done yourself just putting it in
order
in our in our single one-man businesses
branding you're branding yourself
constantly i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing i'm just surviving then if you
don't know what you're doing here i
don't know what i'm doing i'm just
surviving because that's all i'm trying
to do you know it's so weird
i agree with that i do agree with what
you just said yeah every day is i'm just
looking to survive today oh my gosh
that's it i don't understand what these
people with eight year plans you know
what today it's okay when i got a pizza
i want to get a pizza i got a bag of
reef i'm going to give my wife a
stabbing i want to hug the kid
i want to make a [ __ ] smoothie with
the dark cherries in it and the little
raspberries and [ __ ] that's nice and
sweet with almond milk you know your
life junior you know what you like yeah
i mean it's uh
it's uh it's pretty interesting what
you're saying because i sit here
sometimes and i go how the [ __ ]
is a guy like me who was bleeding from
his neck after he was doing blow still
in los angeles
and still swinging i haven't made
nothing
i'm amazed by the fact
i'm still swinging comically like i'm
gonna taper special on saturday this is
the first time anybody's even considered
me for a special and i've been doing
this for 25 years but you want me to
tell you something
guess what
i'm ready
i know you're right like that's the
crazy thing like i wasn't ready 10 years
ago to do what i'm about to do two days
right now it's a
life in life is
it's an evolutionary process
and it's a constant process of daily
maturation in everybody's life and
career and and respect to what you're
doing do you think for one second that
the 10 years from now you're not going
to know more than you know today you
know
yeah that's the beauty of life knowledge
you know and how to do it right how to
go from point a to point b in a straight
line instead of like a lot of
hippy-dippy people do out here in l.a
and they gotta have the meeting and go
over here and go over here just give me
the freaking answer you know let's just
get this done time's precious
time is [ __ ] precious man that's what
they call that's what they call the
opportunity cost of time you know you
sit here and you go 53.
i remember being 33. you know i'll give
a finger to be 33 with what i know now
you'd give a finger to be 33 physically
with a brain
that's physically all the knowledge you
have no we just said the same thing
right yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
yeah if you could do this again with
what you know now at 33 it wouldn't have
stopped me at the age of 40 i would have
been running maine you might scared of
taking over [ __ ] maine with three
[ __ ] puerto ricans in the knife might
scare me at 33 to have a brain that
knows as much as i know now at 59 it's
not even the brain it's the uh
it's the confidence and the
there's a word don't you believe that
confidence is safe show me somebody that
wasn't confident when they're 20
unless you know they've really earned
their craft they're probably just not
going to be that kind of person that'll
ever be totally confident you know show
me a board of 20. i'll show you a board
60. but it's not the word the word isn't
confident when denzel washington what
you're saying with denzel and angelina
jolie where he's in a bed
and she's like a [ __ ] crime
investigator he tells her what to look
for absolutely
when they're looking for the gentleman
he says something he goes he's older
because he's cautious he's more precise
you know when you get older you get more
you uh you get more bang for the bucks
when i know for a fact i got three moves
if you come up to me and say give me
your money joey i got a leg to the kick
i got a punch to the throat another leg
to the kick
one of those things has to take you down
and nothing to do i'm doomed i'm out of
breath i'm huffing and puffing help mr
wizard and my anxiety takes over right
but you know this going in you know
i don't know what my point is i'm
smoking so much i was trying to figure
out your point there but i was just i
think sally was building into something
oh no you only when you get older you
have this confidence
but you also have this control
you know it's called experience joey
it's experience it's exciting
i'll sit lee how old are you 28. 28.
okay i'm 59. you know the difference
between us what 31 years of experience
right absolutely joey you're how old 53
i'm 59 you know what's different between
us six more years of experience you know
the difference between most people and
us you got [ __ ] more experience than
i have at 53 i'm kidding all the
experiences you've been through you've
lived an incredible life joey but it's
similar but it's weird because
i have lee lee went to emerson college
lee likes [ __ ] goofy movies and
orange is the new black
oh you said it right stuff like that
you
know give me an idea of a goofy movie
uh give me one of your favorite movies
it's not my favorite movies that he
hates he just hates when i watch new
movies
like if i go if i if my girlfriend took
me to the uh
it was awful the
amy poehler uh whatever her name is from
30 rock tina fey movies oh sisters or
whatever yeah that movie a couple years
ago and he just he just
when he when i when he calls me and i'm
at the movies he just sighs next did you
watch rifki
what's wrong with you what richie the
one the thing i sent you yeah wait wait
wait wait wait beat some up and [ __ ] put
on youtube for a second i want to show
my man if he remembers this what's
happening on midnight express rifki i
don't think
no i emailed it to the gods just please
midnight express rifky watch up the
questions guys talk about a frightening
movie jesus christ don't even i sent lee
three clips last night yesterday at the
comedy store before i went up i spoke to
these him
another friend of mine joe milosh and a
friend of mine from caa
ryan and we're talking about movies
and we're talking about the original
mechanic how
this 24 the first 20 minutes of the
movie there's no
dialogue
it's him yeah we're talking about jam
michael vincent charlie all right
fighting rifky charles bronson and jan
michael this is the first one yeah right
there that one
this is a movie that came out that is so
[ __ ] frighteningly
it's so [ __ ] frightening
this guy was oh my god
wow
look at rifty sold them out lady
it's a tremendous [ __ ] scene
midnight express i think 1978
this country don't remember this movie
anymore
they're both in the jail
rift he's the [ __ ] pimp
he's a [ __ ] jailhouse rat
this poor [ __ ] americans got like 30
years he's got no look he's going he's
having a nervous breakdown it's a
moroccan jail right yeah it's a moroccan
jail he tried to get the hash out of
morocco
guys if you've never seen this [ __ ]
movie it's an education true story yeah
true story true story
put the music in a lot that's the music
here at 7 11 in chandler
it is
he's having another breakdown
all right
tremendous
tremendously he's the jailhouse rat bam
look at him
he spits in his tongue
this is what america was america
[ __ ] now this is a [ __ ]
movie right here baby boy
this is what you got to start watching
every morning this poor guy died at age
in real life god bless his soul
tremendous american [ __ ] filmmaking
did he get it shooting this no he just
got it years later it's a tremendous
movie guys if you ever watch this
how to drop knowledge on these [ __ ]
look at that look at his face oh i think
that's what [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
we're talking movies and like you uh
you've talked about the mechanic the
first mechanic yeah you know they're
remaking it again they did it twice yeah
i think i hear i hear it's being made
again they got another one coming out
so
charles bronson is stabbing himself in
the [ __ ] neck
was he amazing though wasn't he perfect
for that role and jan michael vincent um
he married one of my best friends from
high school i told lee and these guys
about who jeff michael vinson set the
[ __ ] bar he was the brad pitt of his
generation
there would have been no brad pitt there
would have been no
the kid from sons of anarchy
gotten whole realm started with jan
michael [ __ ] vincent i just watched
big wednesday coming back on the plane
come on yeah well john miller's
he he uh used to go to my mother's house
for sunday brunch and then they filmed
that in malibu you know down there and
uh i'd know jan for quite a while and
jan tragically
is you know how you know he's not doing
well right he has he had his leg
amputated
he uh he was serious alcoholic
had problems with drugs got arrested for
actually my friend from high school he
married got arrested for domestic abuse
um a couple things like that chad
mcqueen steve mcqueen's son
uh when after steve died had his own you
know little film career and started
producing films and when jan michael was
at the point past airwolf
where he just was wasn't the same guy
that look he was remember how beautiful
let's be honest we're talking like
people go brad pitt's beautiful jan
michael vincent was the hitman he was
the
there was a part where he had the long
hair he did a movie before
uh the world's greatest athlete he did
one before that like him and a girl in
the lagoon wasn't that him
no you're thinking ricky schroeder that
was
that was what movie was he give me let
me get imdb imdb [ __ ] what's his name
again michael jack michael vincent
but what happened is is that um
when his career started subsiding chad
gave a movie and a role in one of his
films you know talking like a b movie
you see on cinemax late at night but
anyway right before it started he had an
accident his face went right through the
window so he did the whole movie with
the stitches all over his face remember
you know again how handsome he was but
now i just saw a thing and uh because of
the drugs and the alcohol and everything
his health got really bad he was the
epitome epitome of health right
and now they've had to amputate his leg
and it's just it's amazing how the fall
from grace can change and airwolf was
one of the biggest hit tv shows on tv
for a long time
what decade joey do you think it was
what what were you looking for that
would be back in like 1960 yeah like
late 60s he did the world's greatest
athlete so it was right before that in
the mechanic
it was before 73.
okay
so what did he do sorry i was on
wikipedia i should have got imdb yeah i
am db yeah
that's the easy way
i used to party at the tranques uh
restaurant with him uh david carradine
um
then came bronson michael parks or
michael parks he said that killed bill
movies
uh gary busey who was my neighbor gary
busey was my neighbor next door to me in
tragus canyon for eight years
right
crazy group of people down there you
want to talk about wild nights of crazy
nights that was called the trackus
tranques uh restaurant at trans canyon
road it was the only place to go to if
you lived in malibu everybody went there
on friday and saturday nights it was
just a lot of fun a lot of great
memories of that place those guys were
[ __ ] imagine i heard a bunch of
stories who what movies was he in okay
so in 69 he was in
uh the undefeated
and then he was only in he was in a
bunch of tv movies in 69 well the tribe
where he the tribe and the survivors was
a series
that's it
the world's greatest athlete
okay that was 73 okay the mechanic i
said up to the mechanic
was a while back
where was the mechanic
oh there it is okay like it's kind of
stupid yeah the like okay so the
mechanic was first okay and then it was
the world's greatest athlete all right
and then it was bite the bullet yeah
that was a good one no no i'm sorry then
it was buster and billy and then bite
the bullet by the boat was a good movie
that was like an ensemble he did a lot
of tv
uh white lion fever baby white
do you remember that one holy [ __ ] where
they shot everything up you know what i
think chris christopherson was in that
tournament white line [ __ ] fever yep
protecting the town town you know that
was one of the good shooting movies [ __ ]
one of the movies uh one of the movies
okay i need the dare wolf then somewhere
baby blue marine
baby bloomer jesus christ that's right
shadow of the hawk
vigilante force i remember that and then
big wednesday was when uh 78 78 right
exactly
hopper
hooper no
cooper reynolds remember that was good
yeah that was good it was really good
yeah yeah barbara reynolds i hear he's
not doing too good right now
health-wise he's [ __ ] 80 years old
yeah these guys
i mean god bless him we're going to be
there yeah we're going to be there 80
years old
you know they hope we're there
yeah yeah but back in those days it was
the three martini lunch i mean people
didn't work out as a rule you saw
pictures of clint eastwood which were pr
photos doing a dumbbell curl that was
like it wasn't like it is today
you know not at all it was hard living
that was an old breed style back then
even well i go farther back my dad's age
you know serving in world war ii that's
just old breed they don't make many like
that well you go back to that sinatra
age when they were shooting that movie
in las vegas
and
they would shoot in the daytime and go
out and drink at night
big time you know they were in their 40s
i couldn't do that [ __ ] in my [ __ ]
40s no but they used i mean literally
they do what two shows a night i read
about this two shows a night
they'd party with the women and
everything until you know six eight in
the morning sleep till five you know
party till noon sleep till whatever take
a shower go down through the shows again
start the whole
process no no i'm telling they were at
one point they were doing a movie in
vegas and doing the shows at night oh
the ocean's allowed for like eight weeks
or something ocean's eleven that's
probably when they made oceans like
that's [ __ ] brutal
yeah to do shows well you know what it's
like you know no [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] first
off you're sitting on a set all day
you're not really doing anything most of
the time
and or they keep you rehearsing like
crazy but to do two shows after that
that's what you know what time do you
have for yourself you had no time at all
well i used to work in miami
in the late 90s you had to go out after
every night did you know jesus christ
come on seriously it was horrific
was it horrific it wasn't real because
you figured this
when i was in new york i left new york
in 1985 which made me 22 years old
i gotta tell you there was maybe
20 nights
and all those nights that i stayed out
until six
there's a couple nights we snored it
till 11 in the morning or one in the
afternoon
during the football game or something
but that was basically it right
then i uh
i never really stayed out all the
[ __ ] time like i couldn't imagine
doing all nighters now till [ __ ] 11
or 2 or 3 in the afternoon i think i
think i paid my dues in that area i mean
i have i have certain great nights of
fun but it could involve a lot of you
know
usually involves somebody i'm with and
having a great time in vegas or
something but here in la or whatever
nights don't go that late i can't even
think about it vegas is another story
creates a whole new attitude but even
then people think i go out and party all
the time after these big shows and
granted do i sure i have my moments
absolutely more than i can remember but
there's the moments i'm sure you go
through it too joey i just want to go
back to my room i want to get some room
service right you want to watch
pay-per-view movie and thank god for
online poker i mean sometimes i just
want to just get away because i'm going
somewhere else in two days you know it's
work
but partying all night like that i
couldn't do that
when i used to go
to miami in 98
it was worse than when i lived in new
york up to 85. yeah but you're talking
miami that's i mean miami's nuts is now
that was crazy back then 98 i would do
the two shows and then i was the feature
act mm-hmm i was not the headliner
i would go down there there we go you're
gonna feature [ __ ] yeah two weeks [ __ ]
you how long are your sets 25 minutes 20
minutes
and i would i had a system i would go
down to the club
i'd get my advance for the night or
sometimes i wouldn't see the manager
but i go in and i get a brown bag and i
take like six brown little
little [ __ ]
budweiser's back to my room and then i
take a shower and then come down
actually do the show
or the shows and then in between shows i
go to the frozen drink place
chamber juice no [ __ ] chocolate oh
[ __ ] pajama juice back there no jamba
juice they have like these frozen drink
places with alcohol in them yeah wet wet
willies
wet willies they had they had one drink
that was 140 proof you know how [ __ ]
up you get on one of those do you know
what that means by the way what when
something is a hundred proof for 144
what does it do with the president
alcohol or divided by two that means
he's drinking seventy percent alcohol
when you hear when you're like six
percent yeah anyway you're drinking 70
alcohol one full of these things uh
it's called call a cab
that's what the drink is called it's
called call the cat there's a new
there's a new one that came out what is
it calling uber oh yeah yeah
this is a hundred and they would only
give you maybe three it was green
alcohol maybe three of them you can only
drink two of them three of them but it
was pure green alcohol that's why you
got [ __ ] up but to make a long story
short
i would go down there six times a year
for two weeks
and if the headliner the following week
was bringing his own feature and they'd
stay in the hotel i'd stay a week and
stay in the condo
and let me tell you something at that
age in 99 of course i would [ __ ] go
out all seven nights of course until six
seven in the morning snorting blow
jerking off bringing a girl home from
news cafe
what uh what was it like in that order
though joey i'm trying to think about it
[ __ ] knows the order was a little off
you know yeah you don't want to jerk off
before you bring the girl home
horrible horrible existence
there was some pleasure in there i heard
some pleasure let me give some shout out
to you and we'll get you out of here
it's getting late [ __ ] cops are
coming
i want
sorry about that
went down the wrong pipe i want to give
my main man bobby sharon a shot i
started a new uh
podcast called cobra cast
how about a shout out to my man ray
majewski
brian o'shea
eddie broncaccio ali raza javid
doyle chandler ryan jacobs and andrew
the [ __ ] miller he built this
little devil and see right here that's
really cool i want to give you some
shout outs let me ask you something
i just found this out you told me not to
talk about it but i want to talk about
it because i think
it's cool and now that i know about it i
won't do it today because there's
something jammed with my paypal not
probably oh i was even telling lee last
night on the way down i go lee i'm
trying to give you some money i got some
youtube money for you
but something happened
you go online
and whenever i go online it's like i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] every plane ticket is a
thousand dollars for me oh so i call
lydia they go do me a favor go online
tell me i was just playing thing he's
like 198. i'm like what am i a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he goes they know you're
watching so you have to change your
cookies
when i clean my cookies i don't know
about my cookies i told my wife i like
the way you describe it but it's fine
so i told my wife lee said you got to do
the cookie thing
so when she did the cookie thing i went
there the other day i got this money and
paid pogba let me pay lisa money i can't
send a dollar out a dollar out to family
or friends like they blocked me or
something
but
i don't know who the [ __ ] was telling me
this eddie bravo you did ebi yeah i've
done two of them a lot of fun okay now i
guess it was one of those guys who's
telling me if we go on your web page
what's your web page oh bruce buffer.com
you're gonna be mad at me no it's okay
that's all right all right this is if
you go on your web page there's a page
that i click onto
and i tell you
my name is joey big dick diaz
and i hear him from [ __ ] uh cuba
havana cuba oh you click on this page
you don't want
without trying to selling and selling
anything no i just want i think
it is the [ __ ] coolest thing because
if you have a birthday party a wedding
people a wedding it's not like a matter
of fact if it's not i love the product i
love it all right well here's here's
what happened is that i get a lot i get
requests like you won't believe for
voiceovers and you know like
announcements announcements right
so i do a lot of weddings right they're
on video on youtube or i make audio
recordings for them and it's really cool
because they write back you know i get
tears in my eyes oh you're part of my
special day that's a big deal for me
right so
i can command a certain amount of money
for what i do like you do and but and
this i make these really inexpensive so
i thought to myself instead of these
fans that are willing to pay hundreds of
dollars for me to introduce them like i
would you know in the octagon as a
champion then why not just make
something special because of the
greatest fans in the world so for like
it's a 99 dollar bill right 99 and you
go to the site go to brucebuffer.com go
to brucebuffer.com please leave
and you click on it takes you to page
and basically you fill out a form and
and like
give me give me your full name
lisa s-y-a-t-t
uh what's your skill fighting skill what
would you call yourself
uh look at the jew foot
yeah
how about the jujitsu fighter it's that
the g2 fighters no he's a jew jitsu
fighter yes okay i like it you like that
okay how tall are you
okay don't lie tell me the truth okay i
was gonna see if we're gonna announce
what we could see actually if you're
filling out a form how tall you want to
be what do you want to be like if you're
gonna announce you're gonna say like six
foot three that's what i always wanted
to be is that we're gonna be okay
how much do you weigh six foot three how
much weight 180. i don't know yeah sure
i have no idea what i'm supposed to
weigh all right what's your six three
let's give you some you know like 240
pounds yeah okay okay where are you
fighting out of what's your city boston
any championships in your life
three-time hummus champion
and i ca can i rig it so it plays when i
open the door to the office mm-hmm thank
you yeah i'll send you the file you can
do whatever you want three-time hummus
champion
okay nickname
the flying jew
okay so it takes a second to fill out
the form and fill out the form you hit a
button and and you pay through paypal
right say it right yes sir okay
pay through paypal comes through
i get the script i get back in town you
know i can win 100 of these a day if i
have to whatever so you pay you pay
you do your thing i get the order form
so get my studio and i'll do it like
this
and
now
introducing
the man fighting out of the blue corner
he is a jiu jitsu fighter standing six
feet three inches tall weighing in at
240 pounds
fighting
out of boston massachusetts
presenting
making his debut
the three-time
hummus world champion
lee
the flying jew
psy
i do videos too
and i put on the tuxedo when you get it
that's what i do for the weddings a lot
yeah
oh you know every time i watch these pod
the other day i was watching rogan's
podcast what's his name was on that boss
route
oh bob i love boxing all the things you
know you figure boss is going to talk
about choking people at the time he took
somebody's eyeball out of something he's
talking about breathing
mm-hmm
and uh
i'm listening to this and he's talking
about how he invented this thing because
when you're trying to breathe in it's
the muscles that don't let you breathe
out correctly and he had a machine it's
like a weight machine for your lungs
right right and it's like so interesting
i ordered it it's great i [ __ ]
i didn't know how to do it i called up a
friend of mine who knows him
he told her he sent me a [ __ ] video
how to do it
you know we live in such a weird world
that
you could get you know like i told them
i didn't get the instructions or the
thing i got i don't care
just let tell them to just tell me where
to go and get the instructions she
called me back i said no he wants to
talk to you you know
and now when i heard this from eddie
because i i saw you down and i'm like i
wonder what the [ __ ] buff charged eddie
i mean that he's got to be washing his
dishes and maybe
teaching jiu jitsu to the poker people
on monday nights and it was like no it's
cool as hell
and then he said about this and i'm like
this is the greatest thing i've ever
heard yeah it's it's it's not getting
sent to their house or email and that's
where you write it on email you pull the
file you do whatever you want okay yeah
we have that for see the reason is
kristin who runs my company
she's getting inundated with all these
requests right so it's a lot so i
figured let me make this simple so you
pick a form but a bing bada boom i get
the form i could sit down do 20 of them
you know what to do one of them whatever
and the big thing is joey i get a kick
out of it because i know that i know
people's reaction when they get it it
cracks me up and it's it's a very cool
thing to do
it's really weird what what's happened
what the internet has added to people
like yours and mine live if i had if i
had the internet when i started managing
my
legendary brother michael buffer's
career
uh back some 25 26 years ago
what we did in that 25-year space of
time with the when the branding let's go
really wrong trademarking and building
his business and sports entertainment
i stand up tonight and and send out 200
300 faxes one by one promoting
getting the message out this happened
that happened now it's just pressing a
button i would have killed it i would
have covered so much ground you know if
we had that kind of technology available
to us it's really great stuff i got to
ask you something you mentioned boss
ruden
um
if you were to ask me in a street fight
out of all the warriors i've met right
over the last 20 years 20 years for me
as of february in the octagon
and in my career in boxing was like you
know seven years before that five years
before that meeting all those great
fighters too
who would i want to back me up in a
street fighter who'd want to get in you
know what i tell you two guys
chuck the dell
because i've seen him at work
and boss written
i don't want to hear about anybody just
put me chuckled down one side even at
their age right now and boss rooting
over here it's like that's all you need
i've never really seen boss rooting
fight my two my two
huh my two my top two yeah dark alley
chuck liddell there it is and carlos
condor carlos commented
there's something about carlos conduit
that's always scared me
well he's got the kill and there's two
fights that i can back what i'm saying
with the kid from gsp's camp when he
[ __ ] put the lump in his head with a
[ __ ] elbow oh rory mcdonald yeah when
he said to him you're behind go out yeah
you [ __ ] zeroed it on
and the fight with the
lawler was it lola robbie roberts yeah
that was rory mcdonald with laura but
you know no no no who did he just who
did he just go he just had a battle
carlos conduit with law uh don't before
he lost to this guy now he had a battle
he did he yeah i know i he had a
five-round battle i think it was robbie
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what i'm saying is i
see how hard for me to remember anymore
yeah it was like uh i could see
i i'd hate to bump into carlos the
natural born killer well he's you know
he's
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot like
that but you also have to think
uh as i'm sure he does because i can see
the sense i can read i can read
we're streaming you know we can read
people okay
so i say i'm pretty right on most of the
time but it's not just who fought in the
octagon we're talking about a street
fight you know when it breaks down it
gets ugly
and you know things and bad things can
happen as i know you've seen
chuck's got that instinct
boss
and has proven it over and over fighting
for sport
under rules is one thing
laying it down over here
in an atmosphere i'm not just talking a
quick you know schoolyard fight i'm
talking like some serious street
fighters it's a whole nother world man
that's the instinct you have to have and
i watched i watched chuckled in that
london fight you know the one with tito
and lee murray and all and i was you
know making sure covering his back and
all man he was walking through people
like they were butter it was like
remember the time machine with rod
taylor and the ewoks attacked like pop
pop pop pop he's like bam one bam bottom
fist on this one pop on this one they
were all coming at him he's just
dropping him like a tractor going
through trees
it is an amazing piece of work to watch
you know it's really amazing when you
see
someone
on the street who
god made to be on the stream
when i was a kid young young young young
i used to i grew up on 88th street but
my godmother lived on 148th street
and there was this one there was a
couple families that had six or four
kids
and there was this one family i can't if
you put a [ __ ] gun to my head i can't
remember his name now they were italian
or white or whatever the [ __ ] they were
mutts you know but nice people right but
they had one brother who when he fought
you know he took a [ __ ] ear or a
finger or
he stuck his fingers together there's
always one's true there's always one of
those guys
you know and i guarantee i mean
at the time i remember saying it to
myself when i was eight
that guy's never gonna get out of jail
because by the time i was eight already
he was in another by the time i was
seven i had started going to my
godmothers when i was five and by the
time like i saw him do something once
like an animal with a stick
that i had never saw anybody doing like
oh you know what
as of right now i'm never even gonna get
close to this guy yeah well you gotta
there comes a point in life you gotta
separate you could just you could tell
who the [ __ ] is going to be john
hinckley or you could tell those people
who's going to be
and then there was a halloween incident
that was up there
and he just
took an egg and what he did he did it to
his own brother
he had like four brothers waiting to hit
him with an egg he hit him at the egg
but he tried to hit him with the egg in
his eye like crushed oh like crush it
right into his hand and the other
brothers had to get off him and stuff
and it was just terrible
you gotta think about something do you
know how easy it is to break an egg but
when you're pressing that egg up against
the eye like that right right right that
doesn't break right
really [ __ ] bad to his brother
the other brothers jumped in i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know in the in the 70s
that
they didn't have a name for that yet you
were just [ __ ] around or something
but then there was a block party and
something happened and he hit somebody
and that was the beginning of the juvie
and i remember making a mental note
going that guy's never gonna [ __ ] get
out he just had that look to him where
he's just gonna get worse yeah
the last five years i've been around him
every three months he does something
i tell people all the time the best
self-defense in life is observation
knowing what's going to happen before it
happens pay attention
don't be a hero you know
there's just so many ways i don't i like
you joy i just seen maybe unlike you but
in my experience i've seen a lot of bad
things happen and they happen so damn
quick they happen [ __ ] quick so quick
yeah
you know uh
i don't even like when people talk to me
anymore like one on the street
like you have to pay so much like i just
came back from new york and i gotta tell
you something
i love going home to new york but this
last time it's [ __ ] horrified
why because the last three times i've
been to new york
i've seen things that are
uncharacteristic of any other city i go
to you know you and i both know we
travel
i go everywhere i go to minneapolis i go
to chicago i go to [ __ ] portland
oregon i go to tempe i go to houston
austin dallas i go to new orleans it
don't matter i can relate
uh
this last time in new york city i saw a
lot of weapons
i saw the bomb sniffing dogs i saw a lot
are you talking about legal weapons like
police and yeah yeah well think about it
you know
it's scary it's scary it's real you know
it's [ __ ] real like it's
you go to new york it's real so it's
just uh
it's still one of the greatest cities in
the world oh my god i love that city
i love that city you know all these
cities that i go to are pretty much
booming on paper for me
like philadelphia has become like this
hot comedy city hall this is my hometown
they just opened up the punch line there
they got helium there they got another
club there
every week the clubs are going at it
right to see who the [ __ ] is the best
hell you know these cities that uh
were not dead 10 years ago they weren't
dead 10 years ago but they were
struggling you know
close to philadelphia you got to assume
camden's struggling
pensacon's struggling violence
struggling all those little cities
100 miles from [ __ ] philadelphia
dying one by one you know canada's down
to no police force or nine yeah i don't
[ __ ] know yeah every time i hear
something crazy about it so yeah
but some of these cities that i go to
i'm sitting there and all going wow
what's your favorite cities now what's
your three top favorite cities in the
states
you know what man there's not a lot of
places i go to that i don't like i i
like i like the flavor of every place in
the beginning i like can i find
something
that makes me look forward to going
there
you know i think at nine out of ten i
gotta be honest this is not drugs and
it's not [ __ ] it's fruit
food yeah of course like i'm going what
the [ __ ] am i going to chicago and i got
one thing on my mind some sweetheart
today said to me when you come to
chicago
let me know i'm going to take you to the
best taco place uh
i'm coming from california even though
there's probably some good mexicans
probably is but yeah chicago yeah i
don't want to go to need no [ __ ]
tacos first thing i'm doing with lee is
we're checking into the hotel room i'm
gonna take a little nap maybe work out
get ready for the show and after this
show our friend pete the greeks picking
this up
he's taking us to get a nice [ __ ] hot
beef sandwich
with a little sausage in the middle nice
like gentlemen maybe it's a thing of
water
lee wants to kill he wants to have a
friend why do you know about the sausage
in the middle huh i didn't know that you
were wearing a sausage
saw a chicago mess chicago dog yeah i've
never had that i've had the just the
beef wait wait i'm gonna show you you
think i'm gonna take it to something but
you have to get crinkle cut fries at
least a small well you've had okay i'm
from philly i'm all about cheese sticks
right
you've had the boston bomb right i don't
know what that is are you you're from
boston you know what a boss this guy
likes unbelievable
it's like a cheesesteak with with sliced
canadian bacon on it thank you so he
loved that [ __ ] he loves that yeah it's
a heart attack in a bun but i've never
heard of it but it sounds
interesting
i'm weird with my steak and cheese i
don't i don't like anything on it
so what do you like [ __ ] bacon just a
hamburger no no i was thinking she i
what are you talking about you like
burgers with bacon yeah just don't like
you like you don't like steak
with bacon on it you're very particular
no i don't like i for steak and cheese i
want steak well done like well well done
like crispy with cheese yeah and that's
it i hate people put mayonnaise and
lettuce on it i like it i see people
getting at subway and putting like
veggies on
that's your first mistake you're at
subway so how the [ __ ] would you even
judge those people once you go to subway
you lose all credibility in the [ __ ]
sandwich world in my eyes you could not
say having a steak sandwich in subways i
had a steak sandwich yeah
you have no idea what you said this guy
eats a subway i don't go anymore goes
home blows his ass out speaking of
subway
speak the subway
that guy the you know the pedophile the
one that's yeah what's his name there
jared jared did you hear that he filed a
lawsuit against the parents of one of
the girls that he
went to jail for yeah yeah and blaming
them for the way they raised her yeah is
the reason that he got arrested
i mean what a piece that guy's looking
at [ __ ] nine years
no matter how you cut it he's just
backstroking like everybody else in this
[ __ ] world crazy you got a [ __ ]
car i got no i got no empathy for him no
no there's no one but for those [ __ ]
guys that guy was parading himself
having a great old [ __ ] time
great old time i know you like charles
bronson what's his real name i have no
idea charles bronson
charlie or something like that what was
john wayne's real name
lisa yeah
marion michael morrison
marion michael morrison john wayne
there's an icon now you also
let me ask you something so how long
have you been doing that little
thing with the voices for whatever you
just launched actually strangely enough
because i would i you know i don't say
anything but it i just launched it last
week good for you man yeah
got to get all the kinks out and make it
work i love it i think it's a great
[ __ ] idea
i think it's a great idea when i heard
that i'm like wait a second
so you could just get it made you know
you met yeah oh [ __ ] well you know it
comes a point where in your life it's
like you walk around all day and let's
say somebody everybody who came up to
goes tell me a joke
right
you know how many times they get the
request to announce or it comes in via
email i mean after a while it's like i
want to get back to it that's what they
want give it let me ask you a question
yeah i know you you're a badass
[ __ ]
just call me bruce jeff you always got a
jew you always got a jew cup
before you know the last thing i need is
you making doing a million of these next
you know ben stiller shows up and wants
10 points you know what i'm saying hey
listen if it happens then great
then maybe i'll even let uh
my agent take care of it actually i like
doing things myself yeah me too
that's a great idea that's a yeah i love
all this [ __ ]
i love all this i love what i do we love
our life i mean it's about being
passionate you know what's that's
something that i like i don't like a
[ __ ] ringtone
i don't like this i really like this
actually
i did that i not a ringtone but this
isn't available anymore but this is the
bruce buffer
app right oh wait
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna play a
couple of the sayings let's see i think
i think you'll find this funny
you're not gonna torture me on your
bruce buff no just play two of them i'm
gonna just let's talk let's talk i'll
find out how fast
i forget how long was this app running
for is it still alive no i i made a bad
decision sometimes you make bad
decisions in business with good products
again
but you tried it oh yeah you had nothing
to lose unless you [ __ ] tried it it
did great how many [ __ ] things before
she robbed herself how many of those
apps did she sell
the [ __ ] kardashian chick millions
millions but she made she made 40
million dollars off that she wouldn't
have known that she didn't try but you
got to try it if i remember correctly
one of the ways that was a recent one
she's making a lot but one of the ones
that she made a ton a ton of money on
actually happened through a legal battle
where the people created it and then she
wanted going after them and then it
became her
thing and i mean just it's amazing how
much money hey let me ask you a question
did it ever occur to you hearing that
story about her robbery in paris did you
have one inclination one moment where
you thought it was a setup yes
yeah
i'm not saying it is you know because
they're suing everybody that says
anything but i'm just saying that you
can't help but think
when the girl listen paris hilton
before that green anchor tv show came
out conveniently came out in a porno
having sex with a guy named rick solomon
that sold like crazy i mean millions
okay claims she'd never had any
ownership of it came out two weeks
before brought a lot of publicity to the
project kardashian had her her tape
conveniently was released you know a
short period before a lot of things
happened you know so very smart marketer
and her you know the rumor is her show
is going to be cancelled listen let me
explain something to you before i became
a comedian before i ever thought of this
at the time
but before i i thought that i used to
rob drug dealers but i also
was listen when i started laying brick
anywhere i went even to eat pizza if i
saw a brick i looked at it and analyzed
it and looked at her it could be better
there's something about life when you're
living it when i was a criminal
listen the first time i read the article
i woke up that uh that monday morning
and i've seen in the colorado paper that
oj's wife had gotten killed i knew it
was o.j i'm sorry i knew it was o.j
because a year earlier i read hey i beat
her on new years or something like that
that cop showed up beat the hell out of
her so i knew it was o.j so i'm not
gonna lie to nobody we all racially
profile
when i heard about the kardashian thing
there were two or three things that
didn't sound right not the uncle joey
first of all i would have punched her in
the [ __ ] head that's what i don't
like
she didn't take a punch to the [ __ ]
head
something's not right there also they
just picked her up and put her in the
bathroom not just that but they tied her
together with wrist you know the the
plastic what do you call ties
and duct taped over them okay your hands
are tied now you're duct taped over your
feet too you're telling me you got out
of that
something there's something right i'm
not saying that she did or she didn't
you know i don't want her going after
it's
this is coming to you from a [ __ ]
criminal and i'll tell you when you make
these kind of mistakes
this is a mistake
this is one of those mistakes that
you do when you don't think of that
you know she went over there it's worth
10 million so she gets 10 million
insurance money
and she gets action on the stuff that
got robbed
okay
i mean there's just so many [ __ ] was
her mother in the hotel with her i know
her friend was and they also found uh
one of the necklaces which was a 33 000
necklace
they found on the sidewalk
so the criminals dropped it you know the
thieves they dropped it
so i don't know who knows but it's
amazing how you get robbed you come back
the very next day of the united states
they made 40 million dollars
what it's like they made 40 million
dollars what do they give a [ __ ] out of
an app you just said they made 40
million on that oh her income is it's
crazy all right so what's 10 million
dollars done nothing nothing that's why
it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense doesn't make [ __ ] sense to me
so they're going to get the insurance on
the diamond i don't even know if they
can get that much insurance on that if
anyway that's that's another story but
oh unless they really liked it unless
they didn't want to they really planned
it out i mean i could be wrong too
unless they went in there it's a great
pr move one [ __ ] cop one one guy was
at the door
you know i mean
i can't tell him anymore i'm just saying
i felt worried about anymore but when i
first heard it how it went down if they
said they would have shot her in the
foot
she was also
she was by herself yeah
completely there was somebody else in
there that's what i didn't like that's
the thing i think she had a friend with
her that was in a room downstairs to
lock herself in the bathroom during this
whole ordeal that's what they said yeah
she was another girl with her was in her
downstairs or another bedroom when she
heard what was going on she just locked
herself in the water
where's the cell phone and the girl
locked herself in the bathroom oh she
had one she had she i mean she had all
she had her minutes to call and she
anyway there's just too many different
variables just weird you know what at
the end of the day when you go food
shopping i don't wish it on anybody
though you know i don't wish that on
anybody with that experience go ahead
food shop it's just
i don't like when people
uh
take advantage of some of these like
it's like a [ __ ] smack in your face
with the intelligence like
like something's not right
i don't know i heard something today
that she went after somebody for saying
it no they're suing they're suing yeah
not just saying it made if i remember
this cry i talked about this on my
podcast this week um
they made three posts about it they're
like a popular magazine or something
they made three posts about it and that
was enough to get them sued they were
pretty blatant pose
you know
well you know what man if the smoke
there's fire we'll see you soon i don't
mess everybody up be nice to the
kardashians if they're still in people
what be nice to them if they're suing
people
be nice to them
i'm just saying what i felt when i first
heard it which is yeah she's unharmed
there's no camera crew around i mean
again i don't follow her [ __ ] career
i don't know what time the show is at i
don't know what the seasons are i don't
even know who she's married to i heard
she see kanye west left during the
[ __ ] concert and he was stopped yeah
he just stops i mean somebody gave him a
pink slip and he just left you know what
man
where was he she's always there at the
[ __ ] concerts where were the kids
doesn't she have two [ __ ] babies i
mean there's just so many variables here
that i thought of that minute but you
know what i got my own problem i gotta
shoot a special
elvis is dead and i don't feel so good
myself as they used to say right elvis
is dead and i don't feel so good myself
so i really don't have time to break
down the angelina thing
and the bread pit thing and you're right
you know your family of course
yeah it's really weird how
it's like sports sometimes you you wish
you had more time for sports but you
really don't because there's so many
[ __ ] things on your plate don't you
think as you get older the day gets
shorter
do the day seem longer
when you're a kid everything is slow and
when you graduate high school everything
stuck in triple speed right
once you graduate high school yeah it
was it's over turbo time it turbo
[ __ ] time and it moves in
10-year movements
like you look at six years you go okay
i'll get i'll take care of that problem
next thing you know it's 10 years
this has been amazing especially
for me it's been amazing it's just life
life yourself yes so far it's just been
that you know what's that dude's name
that one that ended up with the eagles
oh
you're talking a musician or singer
musician guitar player from detroit
oh geez life whatever that song is
uh not rocky mountain highs guys yeah
yeah yeah
uh what's the song he's saying life
ain't that bad white paint that bad yeah
oh god who's his name you're killing me
that rocky mountain high what a song
that was classic rock and roll there's
nothing like that
let me see who wrote rocky mountain
highly
not john denver
rocky mountain rocky mountain high was
john denver right what's the song we're
looking for
uh
the rocky mountain way that is better
than the way we came away
and he had the slider right right now
what's the other now think of that guy's
name but not the john denver one
mountain way rocky mountain west that's
high that's high yeah that's high way
why is that high
because you're harley
w.a joe walsh yeah joe walsh joe walsh
now preston joe walsh
the song not rocky mountain way but the
other one
my life's
life's been good to me so far life's
been good listen to the beginning of
that late click done
oh [ __ ]
wednesday night
this guy could play them
there's a great [ __ ] gym yeah we'll
close with this lately
anyway brother
i'm happy that you can make it up to the
show tonight i was happy when you called
me the other day i was saying your phone
rang or christmas joey joey i'm gonna
kill this call you know like i'll call
you back joey what's up and you know you
invite me on and it's like normally i'm
just booked man it's like you know i
would i would have canceled something to
be here with you tonight joey you're one
of my favorite people and we always get
along we always have a good time i
always see on the flights and stuff you
know i just
i don't stay for the ufc's no more ever
since i had the baby it's tough for me
to sit down
joey you're a dad it's do you have to
justify
yeah for me to tell my wife and she's
not gonna say nothing dummy it's just me
in my own personal head i'm like it's
tough for me to go well i'm gonna go do
a gig with joe on friday and then stay
saturday i know that she likes a little
yoga on saturday
you know give her an hour to go get a
coffee get some shoes the baby's three
and a half i don't mind watching and
taking it to the park and [ __ ] so
when i go to those ufcs i get the [ __ ]
out of that six i'm in burbank at 7 30
so she could catch 9 a.m yoga you know
that's what you got i think that's
beautiful that's you guys you take care
of yourself and you know what i come
home and i watch the ufc how many ufc's
i have been to 25 30 of them what do i
give a [ __ ]
i'm very happy i'm content i saw really
good fighters i saw chuck ledell smack
the [ __ ] out of 22 000 people
you know one thing you know that any big
ufc if that's a show you want to go to
because somebody special is fighting you
know you'll be able to go
so
nice nice to have choices isn't it relax
be with your child be with your lady
that's what life's all about man it's
family familia
you know you just have to make
sacrifices a couple weeks ago black
sabbath was doing their final show at
the hollywood bulb you didn't see it no
because i got options i got [ __ ]
things to do i had to do this show
lee and i were in austin texas we
couldn't do the podcast on sunday night
we were both beat
so monday it had to be you know it
worked out it was a great podcast and
you know what every [ __ ] final tour
they always come around one more time
yeah i know they always do one that the
accountants go do you know we finally
made stones are in their seventies
aren't they
yes and i was just going around staying
there last weekend and this weekend
coming that's what you're telling me did
the stones really play in cuba yeah holy
[ __ ]
i saw that i
forget why i saw a clip
on like a documentary a delegate
documentary
and i can't believe that has been crazy
the stones are out there they're not you
know
you know you want to say to yourself i'm
getting old
then you look at the stones and then you
look at i think it was rogan posted a
video of mick jagger
doing a workout at 70 years old oh yeah
yeah dancing workout routines and moving
his hips and whatnot that's what that's
why he keeps going he took care of
himself you know yeah you know when i
did grudge match with de niro
for an hour a day before everything for
the last 30 years denero does an hour of
jumping jacks calisthenics push-ups
stretches he's in incredible shape
unbelievable shape when you look at him
and that was he was 71 i think in grudge
match yeah you know i remember talking
to his trainer and he's been with the
same trainer since uh
the boxing movie the raging ball
look at the shape he got in the raging
bullet the shape he was in even older
when he was in cape fear i mean you know
it's he's such an amazing actor
you know what man
that guy i grew up on it
me too there's no way to look past that
i grew up on that man that's a [ __ ]
weird thing to say like you grew up on
that [ __ ] dude it's amazing yeah it's
amazing to me too
absolutely i can think of other actors
that are like that ones that i
disrespected i i grew up on pacino
i grew up on charles bronson you know
when i got
when i got to new york city from cuba
charles bronson was just starting to bit
slap people i don't remember the great
escape and the other one with the 12
guys the one with the seven guys oh the
uh uh the dirty does the dirty dozen
another one with the seven guys that he
played one of the [ __ ] slingers with
uh with steve uh that was steve mcqueen
that was called the magnificent seven
that they just did the remake
they should all be shot in hell
they should all be shot in hell for
remaking remaking that [ __ ] movie
i jumped on the the movie that got me
that charles bronson made
i don't know what it's in my dna tell me
what is it about i'll tell you when they
got mine was
hard times where he played the bare
knuckle boxer well hard times was one of
those movies but the movie that got me
the first one
was uh death wish
because oh yeah death wish the rape
scene is so [ __ ] horrific it's brutal
it's brutal as i i watched it i had to
be a 10 year old child at that time it's
brutal it was brutal it's whatever
and that scene so when charles bronson
started doing that even at my early
catholic
uh prude age i was like okay i get what
charles bronson's doing and i approve it
you know like let him go shoot people an
eye for an eye his wife died his
daughter's an insane asylum
an eye for a [ __ ] eye you know
and that was the first one hard times
was another one that got me so good the
mechanic got me stoned
killer got me whatever that sound kills
don't kill her stone killer got me uh
the one with the watermelons got me
he did a at western called chatosland
shadowslam was one of the first ones in
new york city i remember still being a
kid
that was an awesome man you know look at
the body he had on was at like
50. were we not talking about that last
night about how with the shape he was in
at 51 when he did the mechanic and i'm
going to tell you something funny about
charles bronze he lived in malibu when i
was a kid and up until the point he died
he had alzheimer's when he died sorry to
say
pretty bad
but um my parents house entrance had
caught fire and they had to uh we had to
fix it right so my dad wanted to stay in
this bed and breakfast and on point doom
out there
and he was writing my dad was writer so
you just write and he would call me
because i just can't write because this
guy is banging away next door all day
morning noon night just won't stop you
know with this girl right
so he goes out who walks out of the room
charles bronson
just not he said it was non-stop it was
morning all three it was like all day
long he was having a little affair what
year is this this goes back to 19 i'm
going to say this is about 19
i would say like uh
82
84 yeah back then the 60s yeah
yeah just
banging away stud man [ __ ]
and that was before viagra that's why
you had a sling big it was there was
such thing as viagra there was no sense
you the hat or you did yeah you either
[ __ ] lift away look at poor lisa yeah
these [ __ ] eyes he hear the word
viagra are you light up i've never i've
i've haven't used viagra i have at once
tried extends just to because it was
over the camera
didn't do anything i wasn't using it for
the length but was it
that's right you had to make that
disclaimer you realize that joey
it wasn't using the phone
listen it's not the motion it's the
ocean league no
well it's not the ocean's the motion i
just knew it didn't do that i was using
it
you say i gotta deal with
he said yeah he buys [ __ ] extends
years ago who'd you give dick to that
night huh would you give dick to that
night you didn't take it home and test
it on yourself did you know it was years
ago
what does that have to do with the
question no
just a random just just just a girl not
like not a girlfriend
that's it's okay to have sex with a girl
who's not your girlfriend and what you
remember that i i well
my current girlfriend will say something
about that but okay let's not get lying
in any trouble no no
no no no no no no trouble i'm just
saying nobody listen if i know [ __ ]
lee
he bought the extent they drank him by
himself no i didn't know no then he went
home and had a cheeseburger
because
yeah i don't even like see pie is not
good because there's fruit in it so it's
too not good but anyways back to the
point i've talked about on the show
before that before paula i had a couple
years i was bigger and i had like a lot
of problem i had problems getting it up
when i was young when i was younger
so that's why i brought it because i
didn't want it to happen because i was
like oh you're worried about performance
syndrome okay i was in i was in the
middle of a dry spell so yeah you're a
bad [ __ ] aren't you happy we
found each other look at you now you're
a bad [ __ ] no no
well yeah be honest with your other
groupies now that you're hanging out
with the man you know what i've had uh a
girlfriend for the majority of it so now
he's been a lawyer he sounds very loyal
i like that
i like that he's got to be a little
soldier over here he can't i can't have
him running around banging weird women
you don't want to you know anybody other
than that
i want people knocking on the door
husbands and [ __ ] please give me my
wife's stabbings
tommy's gonna make her a podcast dog i
don't need that [ __ ] in my life that's
that'd be a tempting offer buff always a
pleasure just to [ __ ] see you you
know thank you you've got uh so after
this thing that your week is when is
your next week will work i go to mexico
city in three weeks and then we got the
big show uh in uh new york city which is
okay mexico city is the first week of
november yeah first week in november
then that's rfk against
uh that's safe sanchos and uh that's a
[ __ ] tremendous pardon me i don't
remember i you know yeah yeah yeah they
kept from san diego
uh eddie bravo's buddy that kid's a
tough [ __ ] kid
oh yeah but i'm i'm sorry i'm drawing
awesome you know what it is i'm so happy
to be just like relaxed i'll do my cards
i'll get into it and once i get my cards
and i really get into the fight because
it's hard for me to throw three fights
ahead i gotta go fight by fighting by
fighting yeah fight yeah yeah i tell
people people hit me up all the time hey
man i need tickets for this video i'm
like listen let me explain something to
you i miss six weeks away
i'm not even there mentally
hit me up the week up
and they get insulted
and talk like what are you talking about
man listen cause i don't [ __ ] have
time to call down there right now
and tell them that you want tickets on
that [ __ ] date they would hang the
[ __ ] phone up on me of course they
would so unless you want me to write
your name down and for me to lose it
because i'll forget this [ __ ] so this is
why i'm telling you the night that i'm
there the first night you call me
the first afternoon i'm there you time
it [ __ ] perfectly
and you call me don't text me call me
and we'll work this out right now
and they don't they don't they get
pissed off at you it happens all the
time all the [ __ ] time and it's like
i don't want to deal with whatever's not
in front of my [ __ ] plate how about
when people come up to you just for the
sake of thinking you got tickets in your
pocket i can't i go through this all the
time they think i walk around with a lot
of tickets because of what i do no
i get two tickets to show i got to buy
every other one
it's fine
it's uh
it's really
because i had you know it's really weird
about the public's perception of things
perception is reality my perception of
things
you know about the public when i was
living in jersey what i thought about
what movie stars made
you were talking before earlier about um
you know as you get older you make
decisions it's like now you know when i
first got here if you call me and say
joe i got a short sag for you pays 50 a
day you're in malibu it's me my you my
brother tito we're gonna shoot it all
right i come down there you feed me you
give me 50. whatever the [ __ ] i have a
good time at least i'm doing it for you
you know
but you get these [ __ ] people call
you in
you shoot that movie while you're there
in the sun
they run out of water they got no
[ __ ] manners
you worked there for three days it's
just about a paycheck how bad do you
feel about that paycheck because it's a
[ __ ] paycheck
so now you get these jobs ever since
after merged with zag
you get these [ __ ] jobs that you
can't believe that's what they're paying
you look at them and go really yeah
what
what happened
oh no this is what they're paying yeah
if you're johnny bananas you get a
bigger [ __ ]
rate right but if you're not johnny
bananas this is the rate they're giving
you you
might as well take it
now ever since i started doing the
podcast
they call me and i'll look at it and go
nope why not
i'm not going to kill myself because i
know there's two by the way's here you'd
kill yourself at 25 and now i'm 52. you
don't have to kill yourself no no no no
no no no no and i know what they want to
do now now
see it used to be okay guest star
so a guest star is a one day guest star
in the breakdown it says one day
[ __ ] guest star right
when you book it it's a one day guest
star plus a table read
plus wardrobe plus travel plus travel
so they got you for three days supposed
to be a one day [ __ ] guest star they
always trick you for an extra two days
and that money instead of being for two
days
is obviously for four days that's right
and that's when you're like [ __ ] i'm not
gonna go down there because it's a loss
for me well you just look wait out the
opportunity cost of time involved that
four days divided into the one day fee
it just doesn't work same thing with
appearances which are you know
the day to travel there the day to
travel back the day there
depending if it's weekday maybe it's
easier if it's a weekend you know it's
tougher it's just i don't i don't have a
set fee
my fees are based on each
you know as i'm sure yours are but and
then of course you got the the movie and
tv stuff that you know occasionally
comes by our pathway and you take what
they get you know what they give you i
get nothing on my pathway do you know do
you know one thing i like about doing
movies and working for sag i love that
freaking blue cross health insurance
that sag health insurance is like the
best health insurance there is if you
have level one yeah i've been with level
two for [ __ ] two years now i can't
even go to chiropractic i can't even get
accurate why don't you get level why
can't you get level one because you
gotta work to get level one i get level
two on just
two jobs a year and [ __ ] uh
and residuals from the movies yeah yeah
i was very lucky for years i was very
lucky and then in 2007
everything slowed down but
guess what the other end of the coin
because all those years when i was busy
with television hours and people weren't
[ __ ] buying tickets and coming to see
me that's right so you have to give them
that you know you have to give in this
business you
you have to pick your battles absolutely
that's the [ __ ] way it's not just
this business it's every business so i'm
very fortunate what i got now feeding my
wife and my child i never wanted to have
a bmw i never wanted people to light my
cigarettes i don't want none of that
[ __ ] anyway right i'm a normal [ __ ]
blue collar cube i love you joey that
don't [ __ ] around i don't know what i
love i don't want to come to your party
i don't want to see the rest of your
[ __ ] house all i want is the [ __ ]
spaghetti and the meatballs you get
these people they invite you let me show
you the rest of that listen so what are
you saying
screw my 60th birthday coming up next
year let me just have joey over for
dinner yeah no no no no i'll come to
your birthday
tell me where to sit and where the
food's going to be served and that's it
but don't come to me and go did i ever
show you my bedroom i don't want to see
your [ __ ] bedroom
i don't want to see your bedroom i don't
want to see it then i don't give a [ __ ]
what you doing there i want to see your
view you have a nice view of the dog i
got a beautiful view okay and i'll see
the dog you got a cat i'll see the cat
but don't show me your garage i don't
want to see your 1960 corvette i don't
give a [ __ ]
i want to see the food you told me
there's going to be cheesesteaks here
the best in town right that's all i want
to say guess what i'm going to guard
those things today
and that's it i don't want to waste time
but it's always good to see you bro so
great to see you too the [ __ ] were
you here let me just give one shout out
as usual
it's [ __ ] jimmy i love it he went
from jimmy to chris
to lee but he's a solid dude i'll take
all three yeah we've been asking for you
for a while this is a joke folks you
heard me say it a couple times i know
it's lee but the last time i was on the
show how long did it take me before i
got his name right two hours was that
sick
that was sick so if i said you
understand i'm playing we had a [ __ ]
good time at night that was great that
was a lot of fun that was a lot of fun
as usual my main spots are always there
for us on it
putting it [ __ ] together
supplements
weights vests kettlebells
weighted bats i mean they're doing it
all but the supplements is where i can
help you out okay
whether it's alpha brain which i always
take when i fly the new mood
you know what i haven't taken new mood
in a while because i'm beyond that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't put me to
sleep or nothing but i love the shroom
tech sport and the shroom tech immune
and you know me always in the protein
mix i've always got the hemp protein
chocolate cause it's the best chocolate
i've ever tasted in my life but if you
go to go to honor.com right now take a
look at all the selection of supplements
they got either the mct oil the tester
on booster there's something there that
you can use go to honor.com you see
something you like put in the
box
at the end pressing church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent off your
order delivered right to your [ __ ]
house all right who does that [ __ ] i'll
tell you that i'm gonna take it up on
that too because i use that testimony
for me on the anna products when i play
those long poker tournaments like the
world series of poker i load up on that
alpha brain i like that album the alpha
brain is very good i like that product
you can't snort them but if your popcorn
is [ __ ] you drink a little milkshake
something nice it's a nice atta but it
takes a while for it to get into your
system guys so if you're planning on
writing a book or something this might
be for you go to honor.com right now and
press in charge boom church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 percent off delivered to your
house i want to thank my main man bruce
buffer i want to thank lisa
and that said i'll see you [ __ ]
in chicago thank you for all the love
and support halloween weekend south
point casino las vegas and then november
11th the night before the ufc
i'm at the wilbur [ __ ] theater
right there
boston i'm bringing lee with me he's
just go out there and jump up and down
look at him he's all happy he's talking
about eating chocolate and [ __ ] like
that
i love you guys and a boston bomb and a
boston bomb don't forget if you want to
order uh
bruce buffer do an announcement for you
or wedding bruce buffalo come to your
house jump out of the helicopter
whatever you need he'll yell uh and here
now whatever he'll do the [ __ ] buffer
360. what's the webpage
brucebuffer.com thank you again have a
all
uh
great weekend and i'll see you
[ __ ] back here monday all right
stay black and thank you for all the
love and all the support and i want to
thank the guy who gave me the hot wheels
in new york for my daughter i keep
forgetting the [ __ ] thank you okay i
didn't find a note and also somebody
gave me a goodie bag from whole foods
thank you very much i took the goodie
bag out i took the note out and put it
in my back pocket but it must have
fallen out i didn't forget it we enjoyed
it i like the salami sticks and the
[ __ ] plantain chips were delicious
thank you again have a great weekend
stay black be safe love you joey love
you too brother
finally i'm gonna pick
so
so
foreign
that's
you